Wenn Leute wissen, dass du bei Schalke spielst, dann nehmen sie es auch ein bisschen ernster, weil E-Sport in Deutschland jetzt nicht so angesehen ist, aber als Schalke reinkam, wurde es auf jeden Fall besser angesehen.
Der Markt für Computerspiele in Deutschland ist etwa 4 Milliarden Euro schwer. Wenn man das in Vergleich setzt zum Bundesliga-Fußball, ist das schon wesentlich größer, weil die Bundesliga im letzten Jahr etwa 2, 6 Milliarden umgesetzt hat.
Fußball gehört auf den grünen Rasen und hat mit anderen Dingen, die computermäßig sind, nichts zu tun. Ja, das halte ich für absurd.
Ich bin ein großer Freund des E-Sports als Sport. Warum? Weil es hat ganz viele Facetten des Sports. 300 Bewegungen etwa pro Minute, das ist schon richtig Sport. Ich habe taktische, soziale, also interaktive Fähigkeiten. Ich muss also mich abstimmen, ich muss Spiele lernen, ich muss schnell reagieren und vor allen Dingen mich auch absprechen. All das ist für mich Sport.
In spätestens fünf Jahren reden wir über sowas gar nicht mehr, weil dann ist es in der Mitte der Gesellschaft angekommen.
Je tiefer man in diese Disziplinen hinein sticht und selber versteht, warum etwas so toll ist, warum plötzlich 25.000 Leute in einer Halle applaudieren und schreien und echte Emotionen freilassen, weil gerade fünf Leute auf eine Tasse Brühe gedrückt haben, das ist Wahnsinn.
Ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit.
Ja, was hat der VfL Bochum mit Paris Saint-Germain gemeint? Beide haben eine eigene E-Sport Abteilung gegründet und sind damit bei weitem nicht alleine und damit hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Max Sackop-Ost. Schalke, Wolfsburg, Leipzig, Stuttgart, Leverkusen, Köln, Hertha und der VfB Stuttgart sind in Deutschland aktiv und ich wäre mir nicht sicher, ob zum Zeitpunkt der Veröffentlichung diese Liste noch vollständig ist, denn es geht sehr rasant in Deutschland und nicht nur hier. Manchester City, Valencia, Sporting Lissabon, Ajax, Amsterdam, Olympique, Lyon, sowie fast alle Vereine der Major League Soccer. Es gibt jede Menge Fußballvereine, die sich im Bereich E-Sports engagieren. Allein in Deutschlands gibt es zwischen 1, 5 und 4, 5 Millionen E-Sportler und 36 Millionen Deutsche bezeichnen sich selbst als Computerspieler. Das sind – und das ist ein sehr gerne genommener Vergleich – doppelt so viele Computerspieler wie Autofahrer. Aber was hat denn das mit Fußball zu tun? Was hat das im Rasenfunk zu suchen? Ist das überhaupt Sport? Und warum machen da jetzt einzelne Bundesliga-Vereine mit? All diese Fragen wollen wir in diesem Tribünengespräch beantworten und ich freue mich auf eine Reihe von tollen Gesprächspartnern. Zum einen Malte Hedderich. Er ist selbst FIFA-Spieler und hat an Weltmeisterschaften für Deutschland teilgenommen. Inzwischen kommentiert er auch Spiele, macht so ein bisschen da. Ich weiß nicht, ob es der Oliver-Kahn-Experte ist oder eher der Mehmet-Scholl-Experte, kann er uns gleich selbst beantworten und ist einer der Gründer der Agentur Beepart Gaming und eine vielgefragte Stimme im Bereich des E-Sport. Deswegen bin ich sehr, sehr, sehr froh, Malte, dass ich dich hier begrüßen darf. Hallo. Hey, vielen Dank für die Einladung, Max. Du hattest jetzt am Wochenende das Vergnügen, mal als Experte tätig zu sein. Wer bist du, eher der Tobi Escher oder der Oliver Kahn, der E-Sport-Experten? Ich finde Tobi schon sehr cool, muss ich sagen, weil er da natürlich recht analytisch rangeht. Ich würde da jetzt nicht den Vergleich wagen wollen zu irgendeiner der beiden. Ich bin FIFA-Spieler und versuche, mein Gamingwissen da anzuwenden. Aber natürlich gucke ich mir auch an, wie das im Fußball gemacht wird, weil so viel kann ich vielleicht schon mal vorweggreifen. FIFA als Disziplin ist natürlich nah am Fußball dran. Das ist bei anderen Disziplinen vielleicht noch nicht ganz so nah der Fall. Deswegen, klar, lässt man sich auch durch den Fußball inspirieren. Ach, sehr gut. Und so ein bisschen, dass die Sprachrhythmen und die Wörter, die kennt man schon. Also gerade hast du ja nicht noch gesagt, dass du spielst da, wo der Trainer dich hinstellt, dass er dir noch gefällt und du haust natürlich immer alles aus. Im E-Sports darf man noch ganz geradeaus reden. Ja, mal schauen, wie lange das noch so bleibt. Werden wir gleich besprechen, unter anderem auch mit Konni Winkler. Seine Stimme kennt ihr vielleicht von Amazon Music oder all seinen Vorgängern oder vielleicht von Antenne Thürigen oder vielleicht auch aus seinen eigenen Streams und Videos zu Videospielen. Er moderiert, er spielt, er ist jetzt endlich mal im Rasenfunk. Hallo Konni.
Hey Max, es klappt endlich und dann zu so einem schönen Thema. Danke auch von mir für diese schöne Einladung. Ich muss dich nur kurz korrigieren, es ist nicht Antenne, es ist Landeswehr der Thüringen.
Um Gottes Willen.
Ja, ja, es ist aber alles okay.
Sehr gut. Da stehen jetzt wahrscheinlich in Thüringen schon manche Leute mit der brennenden Heugabel auf den Straßen und womit mit Recht. Das tut mir sehr leid. Aber schön, dass es geklappt hat zum zweitschönsten Thema, über das du sprechen kannst. Das Schönste wäre natürlich der 1. FC Nürnberg. Aber das holen wir mal. Und dann freue ich mich sehr über die Anwesenheit von Tim Reichert. Ihn haben wir zum Teil auch schon im Intro gehört. Ihr spielt hier selbst Profi-Fußball, unter anderem bei Rot-Weiß-Oberhausen. Seit 2016 ist er im E-Sport-Bereich des FC Schalke 04 tätig, aktuell als Chief Gaming Officer, was auch immer das ist. Hallo Tim.
Glück auf aus Schalke. Freue mich sehr, dabei zu sein und mal schauen, was für Fragen du für uns auf Lager hast.
Ja, ich vermute zumindest im Anfangsteil wird es euch wenig überraschen, denn der E-Sport ist ein Bereich, der noch relativ jung ist in Deutschland und deswegen werden die immer gleichen Fragen von immer anderen Leuten gestellt und beantwortet – jetzt auch im Rasenfunk. Bevor wir damit aber anfangen, danke ich noch den Rasenfunk-Supportern Flixius, Manfred, Thomas und Andreas S. Der Rasenfunk ist frei von Werbung, Sponsoren und liegt hinter keiner Paywall. Und warum? Wegen Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer wie euch.
Vielen Dank.
Wer uns unterstützen möchte, kann das tun unter rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. So, jetzt wollen wir aber loslegen. Und zwar ganz, ganz, ganz am Anfang, Malte. Was ist denn eigentlich eSport oder eSports? Also als simple Definition würde ich erstmal sagen, dass es das wettbewerbsorientierte Computerspielen ist. Man kann da sicherlich nochmal unterscheiden zwischen zum Beispiel Einzelspielen, wo man dann eins gegen eins spielt, aber meistens wirklich immer gegen einen echten Menschen oder eben Teamspielen wie League of Legends zum Beispiel, wo man dann ein Team aufeinander trifft. Und es gibt denke ich so drei zentrale Plattformen, das ist einmal auf dem PC. Und es gibt dann eben die beiden Konsolen, die Playstation 4 und die Xbox One. Und für diese jeweiligen Plattformen dann auch unterschiedliche Spiele, in denen gespielt wird. Da sieht man, dass sich jemand seine Antwort schon zurechtgelegt hat. Das finde ich sehr gut. Aber wir haben hier sogar gerade frisch im Kopf. Da sieht man, was für ein Profi du einfach bist, Malte. Aber ist denn jetzt einfach nur, wenn ich ein Videospiel spiele gegen jemand anderen, ein Computerspiel, ist das einfach schon E-Sport? Kann man das so bezeichnen oder setzt das noch ein Grad der Professionalisierung voraus? Wie weit ist der Begriff da definiert? Ja, also ich glaube, das ist immer ein fließender Übergang. Es gibt einmal so Casual Gaming. Das ist eigentlich das, was wir alle machen, wenn wir einfach mal die Konsole oder den PC anwerfen und ein bisschen drauf loszocken. Und ich glaube, der Unterschied ist einfach, wenn man bewusst sagt, hey, ich mache das jetzt hier wettbewerbsorientiert. Ich habe irgendwie das Ziel, besser zu werden. Ich möchte mich mit anderen Leuten wirklich messen und nicht einfach nur drauf loszocken. Aber dieser Übergang, der ist, denke ich, einfach fließend.
Ich glaube auch hier, vielleicht kann ich mal hier einhaken. Der Unterschied in der Definition ist meiner Meinung nach… Also Fußball in der Kreisliga C ist ja genauso Sport wie Fußball in der Bundesliga. Ich glaube, was Malte gerade sagte, ist schon richtig. Auf der Couch mit seinen Kumpels FIFA spielen ist am Ende des Tages genauso E-Sport wie in den vollen Stadien auf den Weltmeisterschaften zu spielen. Das ist halt nur ein anderes Niveau und ein anderes Level. Also das, würde ich sagen, ist dann der breiten Sport.
Andererseits könnte ich jetzt aber natürlich auch sagen, wenn ich zu Hause mit meinen Zwillingen Halmer spiele, dann mache ich da ja auch dann Sport. Und wenn ich jetzt dann bundesweit spielen würde, würde ich dann ein professioneller Halmer-Spieler sein. Das stellt so ein bisschen die Frage, Konni, nachdem, was sind eigentlich so die Spiele, die gespielt werden? League of Legends ist gerade schon gefallen. Wir müssen das alles nochmal erklären, weil wir können nicht davon ausgehen, dass alle Hörerinnen und Hörer sämtliche Spiele kennen. Also was sind so die gängigen und größten E-Sport-Spiele?
Also das hat sich natürlich ein bisschen verändert auch im Laufe der Zeit. So die Anfänge waren, glaube ich, damals alles, was so aus dem asiatischen Raum mit StarCraft irgendwie um die Ecke kam. StarCraft ist im Moment immer noch ein E-Sport-Titel, also der zweite Teil davon zumindest. StarCraft 2 hat aber nicht mehr die Bedeutung, wie es mal hatte. Also tatsächlich, du hast League of Legends schon genannt, das ist also so ein MOBA, ein Echtzeit-Strategiespiel. Ein MOBA, ein Multiplayer Online Battle Arena Spiel. Das ist nochmal kurz erklärt, also MOBA ist ein Multiplayer Online Battle Arena. Das heißt, man spielt immer auf einer Karte, das heißt, die Karte sieht immer gleich aus und es spielen dann immer 5 gegen 5 und die Spieler sind alle real, also es sind immer zehn Menschen an einem Spiel quasi beteiligt und jeder pickt sich einen Helden. Da gibt es also über 100 Helden, aus denen man wählen kann und die Komposition des Teams eben und die eigene individuelle Fähigkeit diesen Helden zu spielen, die macht dann eben den Erfolg aus, also individuell und eben auch Teamtaktik so. Das ist also ähnlich wie auch beim Fußball, wo es eben einen Einzelkünstler wie Ronaldo gibt, aber eben auch das Team an sich, das irgendwie die Strategie verfolgen muss.
Was macht man denn da? Also es gibt Spiele, da schießt man aufeinander, Counter-Strike kommen wir sicherlich auch noch mal zu im Verlauf dieser Sendung und dann gibt es aber eben Spiele wie das von dir eben genannte. Kannst du noch kurz beschreiben für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das vielleicht sogar noch nie gesehen haben und selbst wenn man es zum ersten Mal sieht, checkt man ehrlich gesagt auch nichts. Ich habe bei dieser Recherche hier viele Fragezeichen auf der Stimme gehabt.
Das ist auch das Problem, dass Spiele wie League of Legends oder auch Dota 2, also die gleiche Gattung der Spiele, extrem tiefsinnig sind. Deswegen ist es eben auch irgendwo am Ende eine hohe Kunst, diese Spiele so auf dem Level zu beherrschen, wie es die Pros tun. Also wir reden hier von einem Spiel – ich weiß nicht, ob jemand von den Zuhörern damals mal Siedler gespielt hat oder das alte Age of Empires. Man sieht quasi das Spielfeld von oben, also aus der Vogelperspektive, und steuert dann quasi diesen Helden auf diesem Feld, indem man ihn mit Rechtsklicks da durch dieses Feld führt. Also Rechtsklick auf der Maus. Und dazu hat halt jeder Held noch Eigenschaften. Das ist immer unterschiedlich, ich glaube Minimum 4 und manche Helden haben eben ein paar mehr. Und man muss halt eben selber immer entscheiden, wohin laufe ich, wie laufe ich und welche Eigenschaft wähle ich wann an und was mache ich damit. Also manche kann man eben auf eine Fläche anordnen, also diese AOE-Geschichten, also dass man eben nicht nur ein Gegner erwischt, sondern eben eine Fläche, also möglicherweise auch ein paar mehr. Oder man steuert halt eben direkt ein Gegenspiel an. Manche haben aber auch nur Beschleunigungsfähigkeiten, dass sie also schneller laufen können. Andere haben passive Fähigkeiten, die sie gar nicht irgendwie aktivieren müssen, die einfach automatisch entweder immer da sind oder durch bestimmte Situationen ausgelöst werden. Also du merkst, es ist echt sehr, sehr schwer, das am Ende so ganz runterzubrechen, weil es wirklich immer sehr komplex ist. Aber am Ende ist es so, du suchst den Helden aus, du überlegst dir, wohin laufe ich mit dem und wann wähle ich welche Eigenschaft aus. Und das Ganze aus der Vogelperspektive und Ziel ist es, am Ende die gegnerische Basis als erstes zu zerstören. Wer das geschafft hat, gewinnt. Dazwischen sind natürlich viele andere Momente in so einem Spiel. Es ist meistens aufgebaut, auch in verschiedene Phasen, in Early-Game, dann Mid-Game und eben auch ein Late-Game, wo verschiedene Helden dann wiederum stärker oder schwächer werden. Dazu gibt es Gegenstände, die man einkaufen muss oder kann, damit diese Helden aufgewertet werden im Laufe einer solchen Partie. Und die muss man sich dann auch überlegen und zusammen kaufen mit Gold. Es gibt also auch eine Währung. Immer wenn man einen gegnerischen kleinen Gegner – Es geht immer ums Geld. Immer wenn man gegnerischen kleinen Gegner zerstört, dann bekommt man eben Gold, das sammelt sich an und damit kauft man dann in verschiedenen Shops diese Gegenstände. Also es sind so viele Facetten, vor allem bei League of Legends und Dota 2, bei dieser Gattung dieser MOBAs, Multiplayer Online Battle Arena Spiele. Es gibt aber eben auch so die klassischen Shooter, also Counter-Strike hat sich eigentlich über die Jahrzehnte hinweg weiter in der Szene verankert. Auch in Deutschland ganz wichtiges Spiel, also dauert nicht lang, wenige Minuten, dann sind die Karten immer ausverkauft bei den großen Turnieren, die dann teilweise auch in der Lanxess Arena irgendwie stattfinden. Das ist also ein klassisches Team-Ego-Shooter-Spiel. Also man steuert dann aus der Ich-Perspektive einen Teilnehmer einer Spezialeinheit oder eben eines Terroristen und versucht dann eben verschiedene Aufgaben zu erfüllen. Die Terroristen müssen meistens Bomben platzieren und die Counter-Terroristen, also die Spezialeinheiten, müssen dann versuchen, diese Bomben zu entschärfen oder eben davor alle Terroristen zu eliminieren.
Was ich glaube ich für Leute, die das Spiel noch nicht gesehen haben oder auch noch nicht gespielt haben, recht erschreckend anhören könnte. Daher kommt vielleicht auch die Angst vor diesen Ego-Shootern, dass das Szenario ein sehr blutiges ist, sich das aber nicht zwangsläufig so anfühlen muss, wenn man dieses Spiel spielt.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist natürlich eine Debatte, die ist seit eben mit diesem Killerspiel-Thema, die wir ja schon seit langer Zeit haben und es gibt aber immer wieder eben auch Studien, die widerlegen, dass jemand, der solche Spiele spielt, auch zwangsweise dann zur Waffe greift. Man muss halt immer sich vor Augen führen, das ist ein fiktives Szenario. Das ist wie, wenn ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, auch mal mir einen Kinofilm anschaue, auch das ist eine Kunstform. Nur weil James Bond irgendwem da keine Ahnung was um die Ohren knallt, habe ich jetzt nicht den inneren Antrieb, auch wenn ich James Bond vielleicht cool finde, dann irgendwie selbiges zu tun. Ja, aber das ist natürlich über Jahre hinweg ein Thema gewesen, ja, in Verbindung auch mit CSGO.
Okay, also das heißt, wir haben einmal ein Spiel, da renne ich aus der Vogelperspektive gesehen, über ein Spielfeld, die immer gleiche Karte kann aus verschiedenen Charakteren werden. Stellen wir es uns einfach mal vor, als könnte ich sagen, ich möchte jetzt mit Lionel Messi über diese Map laufen und der hat eben die Sondereigenschaften, dass er besonders schnell ist, dass er wiese flink ist, dass er so klein ist, dass die Leute über ihn drüberhauen und dass sein Schuss sehr präzise ist und dann versuche ich diese Eigenschaften so einzusetzen, dass ich von den gegnerischen fünf Gegnern, die so ausschalte, austrickse, dass ich deren Basis einnehmen kann. Das ist das eine, League of Legends und Dota und jetzt im Counter-Strike, wo man virtuell aufeinander schießt und versucht eben im Team das andere Team zu eliminieren letztlich.
Ja, es gibt natürlich noch ein paar mehr. Also wenn wir bei diesen Ego-Shooter sind, müssen wir auch Overwatch nennen. Das ist eher dann ein bisschen Comic-artiger aufgezogen mit sehr unrealistischen Fähigkeiten und Eigenschaften. Die können also sehr hoch hüpfen. Da hast du sogar irgendwie einen Gorilla mit dabei und so. Das ist dann noch mal so ein bisschen abstrakter. Das gibt es natürlich auch. Starcraft 2 habe ich auch noch erwähnt. Es gibt so ein paar kleinere, aber ich glaube so die Platzhirsche sind halt die. Und dazu gesellt sich im Moment auch eine neue Gattung. Das sind die Battle Royale Spiele. Also die Spiele, wo du quasi auf eine Karte kommst mit 100 anderen Spielern oder mit 99 anderen Spielern und der, der als letztes überlebt, gewinnt. Da gibt es im Moment zwei Spiele, die sehr oben sind in den Charts. Das ist einmal Player Unknowns Battlegrounds, das sogenannte PUBG. Und dann hast du Fortnite, was im Moment durch die Decke geht. Das ist dann auch eben ein bisschen der Unterschied. Ich würde das auch ähnlich vergleichen wie CS oder Overwatch. Das eine ist sehr realistisch, also in dem Fall PUBG, und Fortnite ist halt wirklich sehr Comicartig und sehr bunt. Genau, das ist auch noch so eine Geschichte, die im Moment in Richtung E-Sport tendiert. Bei PUBG gab es auch schon entsprechende Turniere, aber das findet sich, glaube ich, im Moment noch. Es ist ein sehr populäres Spiel an sich, aber inwieweit sich das dann auch wirklich manifestieren wird, das zeigt die Welt. Und eine Sache noch ganz kurz, es gibt noch die Kategorie der Sammelkartenspiele, der virtuellen, also wie man das damals vielleicht bei Magic the Gathering oder so gemacht hat, gibt es halt Spiele wie Hearthstone, wo man eben sammelt die Kartendex zusammenstellt und versucht dann den Gegner mit seinen besseren Kartenkompositionen platz zu machen.
Ach, Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, der Erkenntnisgewinn für meine Hörerinnen und Hörer innerhalb von ein paar Minuten Rasenfunk war noch nie höher.
Und FIFA haben wir natürlich vergessen. Hallo?
Ich habe gerade überlegt, Konni, ob wir es schon genannt haben. Das wäre jetzt natürlich ein Ding gewesen.
Ich habe gewartet, dass du irgendwann kommst, Malte.
Da steuert man sehr platter und man muss immer wieder Geldsäcken ausweichen.
Das hast du gesagt.
Da habe ich das richtig beschrieben.
Nein, also das ist eine Fußballsimulation. Das heißt, das ist das, was am nächsten am Sujet des Rasenfunks auch dran ist. Das heißt, ich spiele an PC, an der Konsole Fußball mit den auch bekannten Mannschaften. Das ist FIFA. Es gibt noch den Konkurrenten Pro Evolution Soccer, aber irgendwie hat der es geschafft, dass über den überhaupt nicht mehr gesprochen wird. Und auch wahrscheinlich in diesem Tribünengespräch wird das eine der letzten Erwähnungen gewesen sein. Das ist ein anderes Leid, was man da klagen kann als ehemaliger PES-Spieler. Gut, damit haben wir die Welt der E-Sport-Spiele, glaube ich, ganz gut schon abgesteckt. Jetzt stellt sich die Frage, Tim, wo ist denn da der FC Schalke 04 unterwegs?
Immer wieder eine gern gestellte Frage. Ich glaube, Schalke, bei uns ganz oben im Marketingbereich mit Alexander Jobs im Vorstand, stellt sich in den letzten Jahren schon extrem innovativ auf, in unterschiedlichsten Bereichen. Ein Teil dieses Ganzen war dann auch das ganze Thema E-Sport, dem sich der Verein gewidmet hat. Warum hat sich der Verein Schalke dem ganzen Thema E-Sport gewidmet? Weil es etwas ist, was die junge Generation bewegt, was die junge Generation treibt, was die junge Generation begeistert. Und all das kennen wir aus dem Fußball. Im Fußball haben wir das schon seit 100 Jahren. Im E-Sport würde ich behaupten, seit wann gibt es Computerspielen? Ich würde sagen, seit 30 Jahren. Vor 30 oder 35 Jahren hatten viele Leute aber noch nicht wirklich die Möglichkeit. Das war auch noch nicht so attraktiv. Seit wann gibt es im Prinzip für jeden jungen Menschen das Thema Computerspielen? Seit 10, 15 Jahren vielleicht. Und jetzt hat sich das Internet weiterentwickelt. Es ist einfach eine Jugendkultur und inzwischen auch nicht mehr Jugendkultur. Ich meine, ich bin alter Sack, würde ich behaupten. Ich bin trotzdem immer noch leidenschaftlicher Gamer. Und ich werde es wahrscheinlich auch bleiben, bis ich 80 bin, bis dann meine motorischen Fähigkeiten es verhindern. Von daher ist es etwas, was uns in den nächsten 10, 20, 50, 100 Jahren begleiten wird. Und warum dann hier nicht offen genug sein als Sportverein und sich dem widmen, einer Begeisterung widmen, die eine neue Generation treibt. Und ich glaube, Schalke steht inzwischen dafür, innovativ zu sein. Und deshalb haben wir den Schritt gemacht, ganz klassisch, um diesen Leuten auch zu zeigen, hey, wir verstehen eure Begeisterung und wir wollen daran teilhaben.
Okay, das ist natürlich dann die Antwort, die man auch erwarten könnte. Aber jetzt könnte ich dem entgegenhalten, wenn jetzt alle jungen Menschen auf einmal rumlaufen würden und nur noch eine Sandale an hätten. Und das wäre so ein Zeichen einer großen Jugendbewegung. Dann würde ja Schalke 04 auch nicht irgendwann zum Zeichen, dass man da mitmachen möchte, auch nur noch mit einer Sandale ins Stadion einlaufen. Sondern dahinter stehen ja noch andere Interessen, oder?
Ja, natürlich stehen da wirtschaftliche Interessen dahinter. Absolut, gar keine Frage. Aber ich glaube hier tatsächlich, dass das Hauptargument bleibt, dass wir ein Sportverein sind, dass wir das ganze Thema Begeisterung, Fans, Sport, Sieg, Niederlage, dass das alles ja sehr nah an unserem klassischen Kerngeschäft dran ist. Und deshalb uns hier auch sehr einfach gefallen ist, in diesen Bereich damit einzusteigen. Natürlich hast du recht, ein Argument ist ja natürlich, es ist hier auch ein Wirtschaftstreiber für uns. Und wir wollen, das haben wir vom ersten Tag angesagt, das ganze Thema begleiten bzw. umsetzen und das auch profitabel gestalten, damit das wiederum auf unser Kernprodukt im Fußball einzahlen kann. Jetzt könnte man natürlich auch sagen, wie du es eben mit der Sandale gesagt hast, es gibt auch ganz viele andere Geschäftsmodelle, wenn Schalke profitabel sein will, kann es ja auch Handys produzieren und das nächste Apple werden. Oder genau. Aber was hier der Fall ist, dass es sehr nahe unserem Kernprodukt ist, sehr nah an all den Kompetenzen, die wir in-house bei uns im Verein haben, dass wir Synergie nutzen und dass es letztendlich der Sport der jungen Generation ist. Und wir wollen damit auch nicht sagen, dass das der einzige Sport der jungen Generation in der Zukunft ist. Das wird Gott bewahren. Das hofft keiner, das will keiner und das wird auch nicht so sein. Aber es ist ein Teil der zukünftigen Sportgesellschaft.
Aber der interessante Fakt dabei ist ja, dass Schalke 04 sich nicht an dem Fußballnähesten Spiel orientiert, sondern eben League of Legends, also eins diese Spiele spielen lässt, wo man eben mit irgendwelchen Kunstfiguren und 5 gegen 5 aus der Vogelperspektive übers Ziel, also über die Map steuert. Das ist ja eigentlich weiter weg vom Fußball als eben so eine Fußballsimulation wie FIFA. Wie kam es denn zu dieser Entscheidung?
Also es ist relativ einfach am Ende. Wir wollen ja mit dem E-Sport nicht einfach eine Kopie unseres Fußballengagements machen. Wir sind ein Sportverein, der den Kern Fußball hat. Aber wir machen auch Basketball, wir machen Tischtennis und so weiter und so weiter. Und der E-Sport, das haben wir ja gerade schon von Konni und von Malte gehört, ist viel, viel größer, als es nur das Thema FIFA ist. Wir wollten uns vom ersten Tag an dem auch stellen und dem auch gerecht werden. Und deshalb haben wir zu Beginn sogar sehr bewusst gesagt, wir starten nicht mit FIFA, wie es alle anderen Fußballvereine machen, sondern wir starten mit einem Computerspiel, das eine Vielzahl Millionen von Menschen weltweit begeistert. Ich glaube, es steht außer Frage, dass League of Legends eins der meistgespielten. Aber was für uns dann natürlich noch viel wichtiger ist vor allem, das meistgeschaufte Computerspiel der Welt ist. Und deshalb haben wir uns sehr bewusst hierfür entschieden, weil am Ende des Tages muss es ein profitables Geschäftsmodell werden. Und nur aus der Leidenschaft eines Wettkampfes ist es nicht zwingend profitabel, sondern am Ende des Tages, wann wird ein Sport wirklich medienwirksam und wann kann er auch profitabel werden, wenn viele Leute dem folgen und dem auch zuschauen. Das ist bei League of Legends und bei Counter-Strike und bei Dota 2 und aktuell auch bei Fortnite und bei PUBG noch eher gegeben, als es dann bei FIFA oder Pro Evolution der Fall ist.
Da würde mich mal noch eine Einschätzung von dir, Malte, interessieren. Du bist ja auch viel unterwegs. Kannst du mal kurz so die Zuschauerzahlen ein bisschen einordnen, die man bei großen Turnieren hat? Jetzt am Wochenende lief es ziemlich gut, muss ich sagen. Da fand ja die virtuelle Bundesliga statt, also die offizielle deutsche Meisterschaft in FIFA 18, die ich gemeinsam mit Konni on Air begleitet habe. Zum einen lief das ganze live im Fernsehen zwei Strecken lang, am Samstag und am Sonntag. Da kenne ich die Zahlen noch nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Aber alleine die VODs, zum Beispiel auf YouTube, die dann immer so zwei, drei Stunden Stream zeigen, sind über 100.000 Klicks gegangen. Und ich glaube, was ja immer auch so eine relevante Größe ist, wie viele gleichzeitig Zuschauer in der Spitze dabei waren, das waren so 17.000, 18.000, was für FIFA jetzt schon sehr, sehr gut war in Deutschland. Also sozusagen ein neuer Rekord war. Aber ich gebe Tim da grundsätzlich recht, dass das in FIFA leider immer noch so ein bisschen hinterherhängt. Und ich will vielleicht auch mal kurz meinen Eindruck sagen, woran das ein bisschen liegen kann. Also eine League of Legends ist ja eine ganz andere Welt. Konni hat das eben schön erklärt. Insofern sieht man auch was ganz anderes. Wenn man FIFA guckt, dann sieht man zunächst erstmal Fußball, weil das Spiel ist ja sehr realistisch. Und da hat sich EA als Spielehersteller aus meiner Sicht lange schwer getan und ich finde, da geht auch immer noch mehr. Es gibt zum Beispiel noch keinen Zuschauermodus, was die anderen Spiele haben, wo man also reingehen kann und wirklich sauber, möglichst aus schönen Perspektiven, die Szene einfangen kann. Wir müssen da immer irgendwie drumherum arbeiten und müssen uns trotzdem vom Fußball so ein bisschen abgrenzen oder zumindest sagen, dass das eine coole Ergänzung ist. Und haben jetzt mittlerweile – das war zum Beispiel auch mein Job am Wochenende – herausgefunden, dass das Wichtigste für die Leute ist, die zuschauen, dass sie etwas dabei lernen. Die wollen natürlich unterhalten werden, aber die meisten von unserer Kernzuschauerschaft, das sind selber alles leidenschaftliche FIFA-Zocker und Zockerinnen natürlich. Und die wollen einfach selber auch lernen, wie man in FIFA besser werden kann. Aber genau zurück zu den Zahlen. Wir haben halt gemerkt, umso besser wir uns darauf dann konzentriert haben und umso mehr das Thema dankenswerterweise durch Vereine wie Schalke etc. bekannter geworden ist, desto mehr steigen jetzt langsam auch die Zuschauerzahlen.
Ich glaube aber – vielleicht hier nochmal um einzuhaken – dass sich die FIFA-Zahlen enorm entwickeln, auch die Zuschauerzahlen. Aber im E-Sport ist es tatsächlich so, wie der Malte es auch gerade schon angesprochen hat. Es hängt sehr viel davon ab, wie sehr der Spielehersteller hier das Thema auch pusht und wie sehr er es zuschauerfreundlich gestalten möchte und hier auch Optionen bietet für Zuschauer, das Spiel in einem vernünftigen Umfeld zu schauen. Da hat EA lange Zeit meiner Meinung nach einen sehr schlechten Job gemacht. Sie arbeiten jetzt daran, dass es besser wird und versuchen auch bessere Events auf die Beine zu stellen. Nichtsdestotrotz ist man hier noch deutlich von den großen, weiterentwickelten Spielen entfernt. Aber wenn man sich die Schritte, die in den letzten zwei Jahren EA gemacht hat und die ganze FIFA-Community gemacht hat, anschaut, dann kann man hier schon stark davon ausgehen, dass die Zuschauerzahlen sich irgendwann auch an einem wesentlich höheren Niveau bewegen. Wo allerdings ich immer noch ein bisschen dran zweifel und Malte, vielleicht kannst du mir hier gute Gegenargumente liefern, ist das Thema Live-Events im FIFA-Bereich. Ob das jemals dazu führen wird, dass wir irgendwie Arenen ausverkauft bekommen. Weil aktuell sehe ich immer noch das Produkt als zu langatmig an. Aber ich lasse mich da sehr, sehr gerne eines besseren überzeugen.
Ich will jetzt hier gar nicht zu sehr Werbung in eigener Sache machen. Hast du vor zwei, drei Wochen unseren Draft Story Cup ein bisschen mitverfolgt?
Den habe ich gesehen. Der war tatsächlich sehr gut.
Der Punkt, den ich machen möchte – und das ist, glaube ich, auch noch eine Komponente, die bei FIFA komplett fehlt – ist eben ein Differenzierungsmerkmal zum Fußball. Da kommt auch schon ein bisschen raus, was ich mittlerweile feststelle. Das wundert mich selber, aber ich sehe, dass FIFA und Fußball, wenn es jetzt um Zuschauerzahlen geht, tatsächlich auch miteinander Konkurrenz stehen. Sie ergänzen sich auch sehr gut. Aber am Ende des Tages sind die Leute, die das anschauen, auch oft Leute, die Fußball schauen. Man hat eben nur so ein begrenztes Zeitkontingent pro Woche. Und das funktioniert beides gut zusammen. Und nichtdestotrotz muss man irgendwie gucken, warum sollen die Leute auch FIFA schauen? Und wir haben uns ein Format überlegt, also WePAR Gaming gemeinsam mit der Agentur Taktivi, haben wir ein Event veranstaltet, wo wir internationale Spiele eingeladen haben und einen besonderen Spielmodus gespielt. Der nennt sich Foot Draft, also ein Ultimate Team, wo man sich so sein Team bauen kann. Und da draftet man sich sein Team zusammen und hat also jede Runde irgendwie ein ganz neues, innovatives, oder bestenfalls irgendwie innovatives Team gebaut, hat sich eine Formation rausgesucht, hat dann die Spieler zusammengepickt. Und normalerweise spielt man in FIFA immer mit den gleichen Spielern. So war da eine Abwechslung drin und für die Zuschauer war das viel spannender, das mitzuerleben. Und ich glaube, solche Komponenten fehlen auch noch, dass es FIFA einfach da noch ein bisschen unterhaltsamer wird und eine Ergänzung oder eine Differenzierung zum echten Fußball schafft.
Also das trifft hier meiner Meinung nach einen absoluten Kern. Man muss das Produkt einfach, das Event selber, glaube ich, verbessern, damit Leute dann auch mit einer Begeisterung dahin gehen und sich das auch über einen längeren Zeitraum anschauen.
Richtig. Und genau das wollte ich jetzt noch abschließend sagen. Wir waren zehn Stunden online jeden Tag und die Zuschauerzahlen sind konstant gut geblieben. Und das Feedback war einfach richtig geil. Ihr habt es hier geschafft, uns wieder zu unterhalten und uns abzuholen und im Chat die Interaktion zu schaffen, weil die Leute konnten dann abstimmen. Welchen Spieler würdet ihr jetzt auswählen? Also da war ordentlich was los. Und ich glaube, das hat FIFA die letzten Jahre noch nicht so gut gemacht. Und die zweite Ebene, die ich sehe – und da würde ich also schon entgegnen, dass ich glaube, dass das möglich ist. Wenn man sich jetzt mal die virtuelle Bundesliga anguckt, ein Spieler, Mürzer, für den ich auch so ein bisschen als Manager verantwortlich bin, der war da vor Ort und hat eben jetzt sich über YouTube und über Twitch auch gewisse Reichweiten und Fans aufgebaut. Und ich fange, der hat da eine richtig coole Show abgeliefert vor Ort. Da waren Emotionen drin, da wurde gejubelt. Er wurde angefeuert wirklich mit NGU-Rufen, wie er so seine – also sein Motto ist Never Give Up und seine Leute haben da NGU, NGU gerufen, was schon für FIFA wirklich neu war. Man kennt das in allen anderen Spielen, Countess Break League of Legends, dass die Stadien voll sind. Und da habe ich das erste Mal gemerkt, hey, die Leute haben da auch einen FIFA-Lust drauf. Und ich glaube, wenn da die Reichweiten weiter steigen und auch das Produkt attraktiver wird, es ist noch ein langer Weg, aber dann kann das auch aus 200, 300 Zuschauern, die es jetzt vielleicht am Wochenende vor Ort waren, auch mal 1.000 und auch nochmal noch mehr Leute werden. Ja, und du hast jetzt gerade so en passant gesagt, in anderen Spielen werden Stadien voll gemacht. Und ich glaube, das ist noch ein Punkt, den muss man noch rausarbeiten für all diejenigen, die sich so einen Stream noch nicht angeguckt haben oder die zum Beispiel die World Finals noch nicht gesehen haben. Konni, von welchen Dimensionen reden wir denn bei E-Sport Spielen wie eben Dota 2, League of Legends, Counter-Strike? Und wo steht da im Vergleich dann eben die Fußball-Simulation FIFA?
Also ich kann zumindest jetzt den Vergleich – ich war jetzt die letzten beiden Jahre, also jetzt am Wochenende und das Jahr davor in dem Dortmunder Fußballmuseum, da hat es ja stattgefunden, das Finale, also die Kulisse quasi an einem Ort, wo viel Fußballgeschichte auch versammelt ist. Und ich habe da zumindest an dem Ort an sich schon mal festgestellt, dass viel mehr los war. Ich habe zwar keine Zuschauerzahlen vor Ort irgendwie als Tal mitbekommen, aber das war schon beeindruckend, also was da schon allein in der Gruppenphase, also wenn ich mich erinnere, letztes Jahr am ersten Tag, wo quasi die Gruppenspiele stattgefunden haben, da war nicht ansatzweise, ich würde behaupten, vielleicht ein Zehntel von dem, was jetzt dort war. Und dennoch reden wir hier jetzt bei der Virtua N Bundesliga, ich würde mal behaupten, bei einer Größenordnung von unter 500 oder Malte, was sagst du?
Ja, also genau, ich hätte jetzt geschätzt, 200 Leute oder so was, 300 Leute.
Und das ist natürlich dann schon ein bisschen enttäuschend, wenn wir eben dann Spiele eben sehen, ich habe das ja eben angedeutet, mit CSGO, die großen Turniere, die ESL-Meisterschaften, dann auch die Championships oder eben auch die Majors bei Dota 2, die Majors sind quasi reglementierte Turniere, also jeder kann so ein Major veranstalten, wenn er bestimmte Kriterien erfüllt, da gibt es dann immer zwei Millionen Dollar Preisgeld für so ein Major und eben Qualifikationspunkte für die Weltmeisterschaft. Das ist also ein neues System, was wir jetzt bei Dota eben eingeführt haben, da füllst du halt wirklich ganze Arenen, das ist also in Berlin beispielsweise die Mercedes-Benz Arena gewesen, da hat auch vor, wann war das, vor zwei oder drei Jahren, vielleicht weiß es Tim noch, da hat die Weltmeisterschaft, den League of Legends stattgefunden. Da hast du echt keine Karten mehr bekommen, wenn du nicht innerhalb der ersten fünf Minuten irgendwie zugeschlagen hast. Da war diese Arena komplett zu. Diese ganz großen Titel, auch damals StarCraft oder so in Asien, das war Wahnsinn. Also das kann man sich nicht ausmalen, wie die Leute mit, auch teilweise verkleidet und richtig Bock auf dieses Event, das ist für die wie halt eine FIFA-WM, wenn wir irgendwie sagen, geil, wir können uns mal irgendwie das WM-Finale in Russland angucken, wenn Deutscher den Titel verteidigt, hoffentlich, toll, toll, toll. Das ist für die halt das Event, wo sie die besten Spieler in ihrem Spiel eben sich angucken können. Hautnah, relativ hautnah, aber es gibt ja auch dann Autogrammstunden und solche Geschichten. Es ist wie ein Sportevent aufgezogen, es gibt Fressmain, wo man sich irgendwie stellen kann, es gibt Merchandising-Stände, es gibt natürlich auch so ein bisschen Möglichkeiten, selber vor Ort bei solchen Events zu spielen, sich zu unterhalten. Das ist schon im Vergleich zu FIFA und da hinkt es wirklich deutlich, ist es echt ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht.
Genau, das muss man vielleicht nochmal sagen. Also nicht nur, dass schon sehr, sehr viel Geld umgesetzt wird bei diesen Turnieren. Also es gibt die International, das ist ein Dota 2 Turnier. Das heißt, wir sprechen hier wieder von so einem Spiel, wo man mit jeweils fünf Charakteren gegen andere fünf Charaktere antritt. Da wurden 2017 Preisgelder in Höhe von 24, 5 Millionen US-Dollar ausgegeben. Und das, was du gesagt hast mit, das ist wie eine Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft für die Zuschauer vor Ort, das ist exakt richtig. Also wer da vielleicht so ein bisschen die Augenbraue hüpft von den Hörern und Hörern, der das noch nicht gesehen hat, ich kann nur empfehlen, mal bei YouTube einfach einzugeben, Dota 2 Turnier Highlights. Es ist unglaublich, wie die Stadien abgehen. Also du hast wirklich 70.000 Leute, die da jubeln, als wäre gerade, als hätte gerade Mario Götze in der 113. Minute das 1-0 gegen Argentinien gemacht. Also die Emotionalisierung, die Professionalisierung und die Massenkompatibilität ist definitiv vergleichbar mit dem Fußball. Stellt sich allerdings die Frage, Tim, was erhofft sich denn dann Schalke 04, wenn unter den ganzen Mannschaften, die dort antreten, auf einmal auch Schalke ist? Denn es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagen könnte, das sind jetzt Jungs, die kommen bei uns aus der Region, die haben wir schon damals in der knappen Spiegel, mit fünf Jahren haben sie ihren ersten Controller in der Hand gehalten und dann hat Norbert Elgert die mal so richtig fit gemacht und jetzt spielen sie hier für ihre Region. Sondern es ist ja einfach neu bei Schalke 04. Es fehlt so ein bisschen Heritage, hätte man jetzt auch eigentlich gesagt, die Tradition.
Das ist natürlich bei allem, was man neu ins Leben ruft, fehlt Tradition. Das ist völlig richtig. Aber was suchen wir hier? Wir suchen im Prinzip das Gleiche wie bei allen anderen Sportarten. Wir wollen, dass Teams, ob es jetzt Teams sind wie bei League of Legends oder Spieler, Einzelspieler wie bei FIFA oder was auch immer noch in Zukunft dazu kommt, dass die unsere blau und weißen Farben so vertreten, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Dass sie sportlich erfolgreich sind, dass sie die Massen begeistern. Und ich meine, ihr habt ja gerade sehr schön diese Groß-Events weltweit beschrieben. In CLL, das TI in Dota, die Weltmeisterschaft im League of Legends, die waren jetzt dieses Jahr, also dieses Jahr, letztes Jahr, Ende letzten Jahres, waren sie in Peking im Olympiastadion, also im Vogelnest. Das ist ein 80.000-Zuschauer-Stadion, das war ausverkauft. Und ja, ich meine, ihr könnt euch mit Sicherheit ja vorstellen, dass uns das stolz machen würde und auch unsere Marke und unsere Farben ganz wunderbar vertreten würde, wenn unser Team da auf einmal auf der Bühne steht und sich mit den Besten der Welt misst. Wir sind da noch nicht aktuell. Wir sind in der europäischen Spitze bei League of Legends und ich würde sagen auch in FIFA. Ich hoffe, Malte korrigiert mich jetzt nicht. Aber ich glaube schon, dass wir da sehr, sehr gut aufgestellt sind. Allerdings ist unser Ziel, weltweit auf dem Event zu sein. Dass die Leute in Asien, in den USA unseren Verein spielen sieht. Und ob es dann Fußball ist oder ob es League of Legends ist oder ob es FIFA ist oder ob es Basketball ist. Das ist ja dann am Ende des Tages irgendwie egal, weil es unsere blau-weißen Schalker sind. Und das ist etwas, was wir mit voller Begeisterung angehen und worauf wir hinarbeiten.
Und wenn ich da vielleicht ganz kurz einhaken darf. Ich will ja keinen Punkt vorweg greifen, ihr Max. Aber ihr habt ja bei Schalke den knappen Cup trotzdem gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, vor ein, zwei Jahren muss das gewesen sein, wo ihr Tim Schwartmann oder Tim Ladger, wie er online heißt, auch gescoutet habt. Und der ist ein Gelsenkirchener oder kommt zumindest aus der Region, soweit ich weiß. Und ich denke, das kann ja auch noch ein Punkt werden. Das muss ich ja gar nicht ausschließen. Das eine ist, wie auch im Fußball, die Weltspitze. Und da sind wir mal ehrlich, spielen bei Bayern München auch nicht nur München.
Und das andere ist aber…
Ja, fast, okay. Bei dir sprechen sie schon alle sehr gut. Und das ist ja auch ein großer Punkt, der im E-Sports-Bereich noch fehlt. Und ich finde, Tim hat das gerade auch gut gesagt. Woher soll denn Tradition kommen? Woher sollen die ganzen Strukturen kommen, wenn das ein komplett neues Thema ist? Da kann man aber eben vom Fußball viel lernen. Warum sollen nicht auch die Nachwuchsarbeit oder auch der Breitensport im lokalen Bereich noch besser werden? Und dann kann das ja auch ein fließender Übergang werden. Dann kann auch ein Thomas Müller, sage ich jetzt mal, aus der eigenen Jugend hochkommen. Aber die eigene Jugend, die gibt es einfach in den meisten Vereinen noch gar nicht.
Bin ich zu 100 Prozent bei dir, Malte, und das wird aber in den kommenden Jahren kommen. Es wird einen breiten Sport geben, es wird lokale Teams geben, die dann am Ende des Tages der Rot-Weiß-Oberhausen des Fußballs ist, der Spieler entwickeln wird. Schalke wird mit Sicherheit auch so etwas wie Jugendarbeit haben. Aber dafür müssen Strukturen geschaffen werden. Das geht nicht von heute auf morgen. Und wir haben angefangen, wie der Malte richtig sagt, mit so Scouting-Events. Das haben wir auch in League of Legends genauso gemacht. Mit Tim hatten wir natürlich ein Riesenglück, dass wir so einen tollen Spieler finden konnten, mit so einem großen Schalkeherz. Das kann man aber nicht immer erwarten. Aber das wird kommen. Das wird in den nächsten fünf, zehn, zwei Jahren. Im eSport gehen manchmal Dinge schneller, als man selber denkt. Das wird kommen in den nächsten Jahren. Und dann gibt es diesen breiten Sport und dann gibt es diese Jugendförderung auch. Und ich glaube ja auch, dass Städte, Bund, Länder an diesem ganzen Thema teilhaben werden. Die Politik nimmt es ja auch aktuell auf.
Was denkst du denn eigentlich? Was ist für dich der größte Hebel? Das frage ich mich jetzt schon länger. Ist das der Verband, der sich jetzt gegründet hat, der E-Sports-Verband? Ich schätze mal, da weiß ich noch ein bisschen mehr hinter den Kulissen, wie das so aufgestellt ist. Da sind ja wirklich aus verschiedenen Bereichen des E-Sports und der Industrie Leute zusammengekommen, die jetzt das Ziel haben, Sprachrohrenrichtung und Politik zu werden. Da würde mich deine Einschätzung und gerne auch von dir, Konni, interessieren, ob ihr denkt, dass dieser E-Sports-Verband der Schlüssel ist, um das jetzt ein bisschen besser zu strukturieren?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass sowas hilft, ja. Ob es der Schlüssel ist? Nein, ich glaube, die Zeit ist der Schlüssel. Ich glaube, dass umso mehr Menschen mit dem Thema aufwachsen und eine Begeisterung dafür entwickeln, umso nicht wahrscheinlicher, sondern umso klarer ist es, dass sich Strukturen dann auch entwickeln werden. Junge Leute, wie wir es früher mit SK Gaming gemacht haben, dann hat mein Bruder die ESL gegründet oder Turtle Entertainment, da sind dann die ersten Leute gewesen, die Strukturen entwickelt haben, das wird jetzt auch immer mehr und mehr passieren, weil die Spielerbase immer weiter wachsen wird. Aber so ein Verband und eine Politik, die dann letztendlich sich dahinter steht, die ist natürlich extrem hilfreich, um das zu beschleunigen. Das ist meine persönliche Meinung dazu.
Also ich denke auch, dass dieser eSport-Bund, der sich da jetzt gegründet hat, dass der schon okay ist und dass der schon auch was bewirken kann, gibt ja auch dann, glaube ich, über nächste Woche diesen eSport Summit, oder wie der heißt – ich bin auch eingeladen – Das kann schon helfen, aber ich denke auch, das ist so ein Prozess, der einfach auch Zeit benötigt. Das kannst du nicht irgendwie übers Knie brechen. Und das wird mit der Attraktivität und auch mit der Generation, die jetzt nachkommt, immer weiter wachsen und immer weiter auch einen Stellenwert bekommen, den die Politik dann natürlich jetzt schon eben realisiert. Tim hat es eben angedeutet, und das gibt er da in diesem neuen Koalitionsvertrag, den E-Sport auch als Thema, der dann offensichtlich in die Richtung sportlicher Anerkennung gehen soll, was ja auch ein ewiges Thema ist. Ich denke auch, dass das schon als Initiative oder als Verein, als Eingetragener, dass es schon helfen kann, aber eben nur eine Unterstützung ist und nicht der entscheidende Faktor.
Das bringt uns ja schon zu einer spannenden Frage und auch zu einem O-Ton, den wir unter anderem im Intro gehört haben. Der DFB-Präsident Reinhard Grindel hat gesagt, ich zitiere, Fußball gehört auf den grünen Rasen und hat mit anderen Dingen, die computermäßig sind, nichts zu tun. E-Sports ist für mich kein Sport. Dem gegenüber steht unter anderem, dass der DFB ein eigenes E-Sport-Turnier mal veranstaltet hat in Hamburg. Okay, wusste er vielleicht nicht. Und eben das, was ihr gerade mit dem Koalitionsvertrag angesprochen habt und dass es ernsthafte Überlegungen gibt, dass E-Sport olympisch wird. Das ist eigentlich abzusehen, dass das kommen wird. Und der Hintergrund dieser Kritik von Reinhard Grindel ist ja der Vorwurf, wenn ich an der Konsole sitze und etwas mache und mich nicht dabei aktiv draußen bewege, dann ist das kein Sport. Wie definiert man denn Sport und ist E-Sport dann einer, Malte? Du fragst mich hier nach Definition. Also ich weiß nicht, es gibt sicherlich auch eine allgemeinwürdigere Sportdefinition, oder? Also was ja ein Punkt ist, ist immer so, Schach ist Sport, dann finde ich es ganz simpel zu sagen, dass E-Sport auch Sport ist, weil das eben kognitive Fähigkeiten erfordert. Ich glaube, es war der Professor Frohböse auch im Intro, der das nochmal gesagt hat, was das da alles für Reaktionszeiten etc. sind. Das sehe ich auch komplett so, ich war ja auch eine Zeit lang professioneller Spieler. Ich muss aber trotzdem fairerweise sagen, und in diese Richtung zielt diese Frage immer ab, was ist Sport? Es ist jetzt halt keine komplette physische Betätigung wie Fußball zum Beispiel, sondern es ist auch sehr sehr anstrengend, aber auf eine andere Art und Weise, weil sich das Ganze eben auf dem Konzentrationslevel, auf dem kognitiven Level abspielt. Und man muss jetzt keinen Marathon laufen können, aber es hilft eben auch physisch fit zu sein, weil das natürlich alles miteinander verknüpft ist, dass man sich dann auch in der Lage ist, länger zu konzentrieren zum Beispiel. Deswegen ist Sport für mich letztendlich auch ähnlich wie die E-Sport-Definition schon, wenn man sagt, man geht hier vielleicht, ja es muss nicht immer ein Wettbewerb sein, man geht da irgendwas nach mit einer gewissen Struktur und mit einer gewissen Zielsetzung. Die kann ganz unterschiedlich sein und beim Spielen ist es eben meistens, dass man sich mit anderen Spieler messen möchte. Und ich finde, das ist schon ein ganz wesentlicher Charakterzug von dem, was ich unter Sport verstehe. Aber dann kann ich ja auch sportlich Geranien züchten, wenn ich dem Ziel gesetzt und vielleicht in einem Wettbewerb nachgehe. Ja, also nagel mich jetzt nicht auf einzelne Kriterien fest.
Aber es ist ja immer leicht, sich auf einzelne Kriterien festzunageln. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch – was gibt es denn für? Es gibt Brieftaubensport, Saussport, glaube ich. Und es gibt ja so viele Sportarten, wo man das ja auch einfach anwenden kann. Und von daher ist es sehr einfach, wenn man den E-Sport nicht als Sport sehen möchte, Argumente dafür zu finden. Das ist am Ende auch eine Glaubensfrage. Man könnte ja auch mal tatsächlich darüber nachdenken, die Definition von Sport, ist die denn noch die richtige in der heutigen Zeit? Das wird ja auch nie diskutiert. Es wird ja einfach gesagt, Sport muss so sein wie – ich weiß nicht, wann die Definition Sport getätigt wurde. Und danach ist das. Und am Ende des Tages nennt sich der E-Sport ja auch bewusst elektronischer Sport. Deshalb das E davor. Der sagt ja auch, er unterscheidet sich ein wenig von klassischen Sportarten. Und das ja auch ganz bewusst.
Ich glaube, du musst halt auch einfach – das sind ja verschiedene Ebenen zu sagen, ist das jetzt Sport oder nicht. Du kannst es natürlich sehen von der sportlichen Aktivität. Du kannst es aber auch sehen von der gewissen Verbandstruktur. Also das gibt es natürlich nicht oder noch nicht im Moment im E-Sport, weil ja viel über Clans, über Teams, ich sag mal auch ein Stück weit Franchising funktioniert. Aber es ist natürlich schon so, wenn du eine Aktivität suchst, dann findest du die anhand der Anzahl der Eingaben bei so einem Spiel. Das ist auch unterschiedlich. Bei Dota ist es nicht so krass wie bei StarCraft. Wir hatten das ja auch im Intro gehört, irgendwie mit über 300 Aktionen. Das heißt jetzt bei Dota auch nicht. Aber wenn du dann auch andere Facetten von Sport mitnimmst, also Taktik, Teamtaktik, Ausrichtung, es gibt ein Coaching, was dahinter steckt. Es gibt Strategien, es gibt Kompositionen, du hast ja viele Faktoren, die da irgendwie eine Rolle spielen. Du hast dann am Ende auch Analyse, du hast sogar Physiotherapeuten bei den Top-Teams im E-Sport. Die versuchen natürlich auch sportlich die Athleten fit zu halten, weil das ist wichtig. Auch bei einem Sport, der überwiegend im Kopf stattfindet und eben in den Fingern, müssen die soweit ja körperlich auch einiges aushalten. Ich meine, so ein Turnier, vor allem auch wenn wir über Dota 2 und International reden, wenn du da ein Spiel verlierst und dann in diesem Turnierbaum über den Losers-Bracket, über den sogenannten Durchmuster, da spielst du dich total kaputt. Das musst du auch erst mal konditionell hinbekommen. Also nicht nur im Kopf, sondern eben auch körperlich. Da sind sehr viele Punkte. Ich glaube, am Ende ist es auch eine Sache. Ich habe das auch im Interview beim Sport-Buzzer gesagt. Also ich kenne halt auch viele Athleten, also E-Sports-Athleten, denen ist die Definition am Ende egal. Außer in dem Punkt Visa. Also es gibt ja oft dann Turniere, die irgendwo stattfinden in den USA oder in Asien. Die Leute sind qualifiziert sportlich, kommen aber nicht hin, weil es dann irgendwelche Einreisebeschränkungen gibt. Und wenn das natürlich irgendwie sportlich anerkannt wäre, könntest du mit einem Sportler-Visum da ganz einfach irgendwie das Ding umgehen und dieses Event stattfinden lassen. Ansonsten ist es, glaube ich, den meisten Leuten, außer vielleicht marketingrelevanten Institutionen, ich denke mal die ESL will schon ganz gern, dass das Ding offiziell auch durch ist, den meisten Sportlern ist es, glaube ich, egal, ob das jetzt irgendwie kompetitiver Wettbewerb ist oder E-Sport oder Sport. Für mich persönlich ist es Sport, aber diese Diskussion ist halt auch wirklich extrem schon lange gezogen und ich hoffe, dass es dann irgendwann auch mal mit entsprechenden Strukturen, die entstehen werden, wie Tim auch schon gesagt hat, dass es dann auch wirklich für jeden dann auch ersichtlich ist, dass es einfach ein sportlicher Wettbewerb ist. Aber am Ende des Tages weiß jeder, der sich das anguckt, was die Leute da leisten. Und das ist auch eine sportliche Leistung.
Ja, ich glaube aber, für einen hier in der Runde ist diese Frage schon sehr wichtig, denn wer haben wir hier den Vertreter eines Sportvereins, der ja vermutlich auch gegenüber den eigenen Fans auch immer wieder das Engagement im E-Sport rechtfertigen muss? Welche Argumentationslinie fahrt ihr da, Tim?
Also ich glaube, hier wurde alles genau in die Richtung schon gesagt. Es ist eine andere Belastung für den Körper. Es ist eine ganz andere Art von Sport. Es ist elektronischer Sport, wie wir gerade schon gesagt haben. Es ist definitiv ein Denksport, wie es dann auch Schach ist. Es ist definitiv ein Sport, bei dem man motorische Fähigkeiten braucht. Und im Spitzensport, wenn man die Adrenalinausstöße sieht usw. ist es auch ganz, ganz nah an Sport. Formel 1 wird ja auch als Sport beurteilt. Und da hat man ja auch sehr wenig Körperteile, die wirklich aktiv sind. Also es ist so ein bisschen Henne-Ei und auch irgendwie so ein Doppelthema. Wir haben schon immer gesagt, für uns ist es Sport. Ganz klar, weil für die jungen Leute, die das auch betreiben, es Sport ist. Und damit sind wir auch glücklich. Und unsere Fans – es gibt mit Sicherheit viele Fans, die damit keine Anknüpfungspunkte haben, die teilweise auch kein Verständnis dafür haben. Und das ist aber auch okay so. Es muss ja nicht jeder immer alles gut finden, was man macht. Das wäre ja schlimm, wenn das so wäre. Wir begeistern viele Leute. Manche Leute langweilen wir damit. Aber das ist ja umgekehrt genauso. Fußball begeistert ja auch nicht jeden Menschen weltweit. Da gibt es Befürworter, da gibt es Leute, die Fußball gar nicht mögen. Dann gibt es Leute, denen Fußball egal ist. Und das ist im E-Sport das Gleiche. Also von daher sehen wir diese Diskussion sehr, sehr entspannt.
Also noch ein paar Zahlen zu allem, was ihr gesagt habt. Es gibt Studien, die eben festgestellt haben, ein E-Sportler im Bereich Dota, League of Legends macht 300 bis 400 Aktionen pro Minute, führt er aus, also das zum Thema Konzentrationsfähigkeit und motorische Fähigkeiten. Der Cortisol-Spiegel von E-Sportlern ist auf dem Niveau von Rennfahrern. Also Cortisol ist das Stresshormon. Die Herzfrequenz in der Regel zwischen 160 und 180. Also sprich, die wesentlichen Elemente, wenn wir sagen, Formel 1 ist ein Sport, Rodeln ist ein Sport, dann kann man auch für E-Sport da genug finden. Ich glaube, das haben wir auch ganz gut rausgearbeitet. Jetzt hast du vorhin gesagt, Tim, dass Schalke 04 aufgrund seiner Herkunft als Sportverein, also jetzt im klassischen Sinne, ich bewege mich auch beim Sport sehr viel, eine Infrastruktur bieten würde, die auch für den E-Sport wichtig wäre. Kannst du das nochmal ausführen? Geht es darum, dass jetzt die – ich überzeichne jetzt einfach mal ein überspitztes Bild, dass die dicken Kinder in den Unterhemden, dass die jetzt auch zwischendurch mal einen Dauerlauf machen zwischen ihren Spielen?
Also tatsächlich sehr überspitzt formuliert, aber tatsächlich, und das hat der Malte und der Konni auch schon gesagt, ist es gerade im Spitzensport, im E-Sport, ist es so, dass – wir nehmen jetzt mal ein Extrembeispiel. Wir haben die Liga Athletische Weltmeisterschaftsfinale. Da müssen die Jungs, die da gegeneinander antreten, im Zweifel müssen die fünf Spiele hintereinander gegeneinander spielen. Wir reden dann also von einer Dauer von circa fünf Stunden, diese auf höchstem Niveau unter höchster Anspannung bestehen müssen. Und wenn du, wenn dein Körper zu schnell deine beispielsweise Konzentrationsfähigkeit verlierst, dann bist du nicht geeignet, auf diesem Niveau spielen zu können. Und so Themen wie Konzentrationsfähigkeit und so weiter, die haben auch viel damit zu tun, wie deine körperliche Fitness oder wie dein körperliches – ich kenne jetzt leider einen Fachbegriff, nicht dafür, ich bin aber auch kein Sportwissenschaftler – also wie du körperlich strukturiert bist. Und deshalb ist es für uns wichtig, dass unsere Spieler klassischen, traditionellen Sport zum Ausgleich machen müssen. Sonst können sie nicht auf allerhöchstem Niveau bestehen. Das ist unsere ganz klare Meinung. Und dementsprechend lassen wir die Jungs, vor allem unser League of Legend-Team, weil das nochmal ein etwas anderes Niveau ist von der Intensität, lassen wir da ganz klar nach Trainingsplänen arbeiten. Weil wir glauben, dass das die entscheidenden Prozentpunkte ausmachen kann, wenn es um Gewinnen und Verlieren geht. Ich glaube zwar nicht, dass jetzt jemand, der viel, viel besser als der andere Spieler ist in dem Spiel selber, dass der aufgrund einer besseren Physis auf einmal dann der schlechtere Spieler wird. Aber wir reden hier von den wenigen Prozentpunkten, die oftmals über Sieg und Niederlage entscheiden. Und da können wir mit Sicherheit aushelfen. Und was noch dazu kommt, wir sind aber auch der Überzeugung, und das ist glaube ich auch unsere soziale Verantwortung, dass die junge Generation oder im Prinzip jeder, ob jung oder alt, sich körperlich betätigen muss, weil es gesund ist. Und das bedeutet auch, körperlich betätigen nicht bis zum absoluten Exzessiv, denn das ist auch nicht mehr gesund, aber so, dass der Körper in Form bleibt. Und das ist glaube ich in jeder Lebenslage wichtig, ob es für E-Sportler der Fall ist oder für Leute, die einen Tag aus dem Büro sitzen und ihre Arbeit nachgehen.
Aber konterkariert nicht das Engagement im E-Sport genau dieses Bestreben? Das ist ja der Vorwurf von Reinhard Grinnell. Er sagt, die Leute sollen sich lieber bewegen, anstatt sich an die Konsole zu setzen.
Ja, aber verlieren wir hier nicht dann die Realität aus den Augen, weil am Ende des Tages das ganze Bereich Computerspielen, das ist etwas, was die junge Generation – und ich sage immer junge Generation, inzwischen ist es ja nicht mehr nur die junge Generation – was diese Generation begeistert. Und das wirst du denen nicht mehr nehmen können und auch nicht mehr nehmen wollen, weil das ist etwas, was deren Leben bereichert, was deren Freude in ihrem Leben gestaltet. Also hier davon zu reden, das ist doch alles Unsinn, das soll man nicht machen, ist doch einfach eine scheinheilige Diskussion, weil wir sagen ja auch nicht, liest jetzt kein Buch mehr, weil da sitzt du ja auf der Couch, das ist ja ungesund, das ist ja auch Schwachsinn und liest bitte nicht zehn Bücher am Tag, es gibt ja Bücherwürmer. Sagt man ja auch nicht, ey das ist so ungesund, weil du die ganze Zeit sitzt dabei, bitte lest keine Bücher mehr. Es geht doch hier einzig und allein darum, dass man schauen muss, dass man solche Aktivitäten im Einklang bringt mit allen anderen Bereichen im Leben, damit man ja gesund und auch glücklich lebt. Und ich glaube, das ist doch das einzig wahre hier. Bei meiner Meinung zumindest. Korrigiert mich, wenn ihr das anders seht.
Was mich auch noch extrem an dieser Aussage gestört hat und was ich nicht nachvollziehen kann, dass der DFB ja eine Institution ist, der sowas auch ändern kann. Also anstatt jetzt darauf zu hauen und zu sagen, das ist alles schlecht und ich will das nicht, einfach mal sich vergegenwärtigen, dass das, wie Tim jetzt auch mehrfach gesagt hat, eine feste Jugendkultur oder generell eine feste in der Kultur integrierte Geschichte ist. Und dann überlegen, wie kann man denn daran ansetzen und irgendwie noch vielleicht eigene Impulse setzen, damit zum Beispiel, wie Schalke das jetzt macht, das Sportliche, also der physische Teil, genauso dazu gehört wie der kognitiv-naturische Teil, dass man sich da einfach versucht, so ein bisschen breiter aufzustellen und in der Infrastruktur zu verbessern. Und ich finde, das macht der E-Sports halt auch einfach gut, dass man sich das Feedback anhört in der Szene und schaut, dass man einfach mit der Zeit diese Struktur professionalisiert und da ansetzt. Aber zu sagen, irgendwie, das muss ich jetzt ausschließen, dass man Computerspielt und Sport macht, das finde ich schon echt recht stumpf, ehrlich zu sein.
Ich glaube ja immer noch, dass sie den Grinde da auf dem falschen Fuß erwischt haben, weil das war ja in einem Interview, der war glaube ich nicht gebrieft, dass der gleich zu E-Sports befragt wird. Und ich glaube einfach, und das unterstelle ich ihm auch ein Stück weit, dass er sich nicht mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt hat. Der wurde da befragt und für ihn ist es okay, Videospiele usw. Das ist das, was ich glaube. Und das ist auch ein Stück weit enttäuschend, weil ich meine, die DFL veranstaltet am Wochenende eine virtuelle Bundesliga. Und der Verband DFB kackt denen eigentlich einfach ans Bein mit solchen Aussagen. Das heißt im Endeffekt, was die DFL da macht, ist Bullshit und schadet unserem Fußballsport. Wegen Konsolenspielen gehen die Leute nicht mehr auf den Fußballplatz. Und so eine Aussage finde ich mindestens gewagt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das sich damit einen großen Gefallen getan hat.
Zum Kontext kurz, das war im Rahmen eines einstündigen Weser-Kuriers-Interviews. Sie sind vorher mit ihm zusammen an eine Konsole gegangen, um Pong zu spielen. Ich glaube, dass die eSport-Frage nicht komplett aus dem Nichts für ihn kam.
Die haben Pong gespielt.
Und währenddessen hat er diese Frage beantwortet. Vielleicht hat ihn das auch überfordert. Man weiß ja, wie das manchmal ist, wenn ältere Menschen Computerspielen spielen.
Wenn er sich denkt, Pong und damit verdienen Leute ihr Geld, und das soll Sport sein? Nee, Pong ist für mich kein Sport. Dann versteht man es schon wieder.
Entschuldigung, Malte. Ich hatte dich unterbrochen. Ja, jetzt habe ich gerade überlegt. Das fällt mir gleich wieder ein, hoffe ich. Derweil genießen wir einfach das akustische Panorama. Ich weiß nicht, bei wem von euch, aber bei einem hat es sich vorhin so angehört, als würde er in einem Zoo sitzen und da wäre gerade ein Gorilla ausgebrochen und die Polizei rückt an. Nachdem die Feuerwehr sich woanders beruhigt hat, sind jetzt bei mir die Vögel.
Bei mir war die Feuerwehr hier unten und ist nicht durchgekommen, weil ein DHL-Auto einfach im Weg stand und die haben einfach das Martin-Zoo nicht mehr ausgeschaltet. Das war's. Entschuldigt, bitte.
Das ist kein Problem. Das kriege ich sogar rausgemuted. Das ist kein Problem. Aber wenn wir jetzt über diesen ganzen Aspekt Kritik an eSport von Seiten des DFB sprechen und bevor wir mal kurz darüber reden, was eigentlich die DFL macht, würde ich aber gerne einen Punkt noch ansprechen. Denn das Thema Spielsucht im Bereich Videospiele ist kein Kleinzureden. Das 5% aller Kinder sollen nach manchen Studien Zeichen von Spielsucht aufweisen. Und man muss dazu sagen, eine 5% Zahl im Bereich der Drogen, Konsum, Suchtforschung ist extrem hoch. Also es ist ein sehr, sehr hoher Wert. Und selbst wenn es jetzt auch Studien gäbe, die vielleicht mit 1% kommen, es ist definitiv ein Thema, was man nicht ignorieren sollte. Was kann denn Tim, ein Verein wie Schalke 04, tun, um dieser Problematik entgegenzuwirken? Dass es eben einfach in der Realität da draußen Kinder und Jugendliche gibt, auch einige Erwachsene, die sich von diesen Spielen nicht mehr lösen können?
Tatsächlich muss ich dir Recht geben, dass das mit Sicherheit ein Thema ist, das man stärker auf der Agenda haben muss und spielen muss. Denn diese 5-Prozent-Zahl, die du nennst, ich kannte diese Zahl nicht, aber die ist mit Sicherheit problematisch. Ich glaube, das ist dann tatsächlich am Ende der Downside, dass das ganze Thema Computerspielen, digitales Entertainment, eine hohe Begeisterung, aber dann auch Suchtfaktor ausmachen. Was können wir tun? Ich glaube, im ersten Schritt ist es immer noch die Aufgabe der Erziehungsberechtigten, hier vorzubeugen. Irgendwann, wenn es dazu kommt, dass es Breitensport und dann auch die Sportvereine gibt, die müssen natürlich schauen, hier Regularien einzubinden, um auch Sensoren dazu zu bekommen, wenn bei einzelnen Kindern das ans Tageslicht rückt. Aber es ist gar nicht so leicht, dieses Thema anzugehen, weil oftmals passiert das alles ja noch in den Kinderzimmern. Und wer kann das dann mitbekommen? Vielleicht Eltern oder vielleicht auch noch Lehrer. Aber dann ist es auch das auch schon.
Oder vielleicht die Hersteller. Könnte man nicht auch einfach sagen, nach acht Stunden, wenn jemand dauerhaft online ist, kommt? Bei Netflix sagt er doch auch nach drei Stunden, ey, sag mal, bist du eigentlich noch wach? Kannst du dich mal bitte bewegen und irgendeine Taste drücken?
Also ja, also absolut, finde ich gar nicht ganz falsch, wenn das technisch umsetzbar ist.
Also bei Nintendo machen sie das auf dem 3DS. Gibt's Spiele, wenn du dazu lang Pokémon spielst, kein Witz, dann kommt irgendwann hier, gönn dir doch mal eine Pause und so weiter. Ist halt die Frage, was es bringt, ne? Also, ob da die Verantwortung nicht vielleicht doch – also ich sehe die Verantwortung zumindest, was Kinder und Jugendliche angeht, schon auch bei den Eltern. Das ist ja im Endeffekt wie mit Fernsehen gucken. Die müssen eigentlich auch schauen, dass sie nicht ständig nur vor der Glotze hängen. Und die Verantwortung würde ich eben dann auch auf PC oder Konsolen übertragen, in erster Instanz, dass natürlich da ein großer Markt dahinter ist und sich die entsprechenden Player da beteiligen sollten. Das steht auf dem anderen Blatt Papier, ja klar.
Ich habe letztens gelernt, ich war bei einer Diskussionsrunde im Hamburger Parlament. Die haben sich damit auch auseinandergesetzt, ob E-Sports ein Sport ist und alles, was dazugehört. Und da war eine Psychologin und die hat gesagt, dass die Spiele teilweise so konzipiert sind, dass sie so einen – ich glaube, Flow-Effekt hat sie das genannt – haben, dass man genau in der Mischung sozusagen durch das Spiel durchfliegt zwischen Überforderung, also Reizüberforderung und Reizunterforderung. Und das sorgt dafür, dass man so ein bisschen vergisst und das Gefühl dafür verliert für Zeit und so weiter und so fort. Also, dass man wirklich in so einen Tunnel kommt. Man kennt das ja vielleicht auch manchmal, wenn man dann zockt oder auch einen Film guckt oder so. Manchmal ist man dann einfach so da drin. Und ich glaube, da sind die Spielehersteller auch gefordert. Ich meine, sowas ist ja klar, warum sie das vielleicht auch gezielter einmachen, weil die Leute möglichst viel sich mit ihrem Produkt auseinandersetzen sollen. Aber da sind sie aus meiner Sicht auch gefordert, dann sowas entgegenzuwirken. Und wir hatten jetzt gerade Beispiele, zum Beispiel irgendwann mal zu sagen so, jetzt ist mal Schluss oder das Spiel nicht so zu konzipieren. Ich fand World of Warcraft da immer nicht das beste Beispiel, ehrlich gesagt, dass man eben die ganze Zeit dran bleiben muss. Sondern so Spiele wie League of Legends, die sind ja durchaus auch zeitlich mehr oder weniger einzugrenzen. Es gibt jedes Mal ein Spiel und es ist ganz klar, wenn am Ende der Nexus hält, dann ist Schluss. Und ich finde, sowas muss irgendwie noch besser verankert werden. Einfach klare Rahmen, dass dann auch irgendwann mal Schluss ist. Und ich glaube, wie bei vielen Themen, auf die man erst stößt, wenn man sich näher damit auseinandersetzt, geht es auch ganz viel um Bewusstsein in der Öffentlichkeit zu schaffen. Also es gibt klare Anzeichen für Spielsucht. Wenn man sich eben vom sozialen Leben abkapselt, wenn man Termine, unter anderem auch Schule, fürs Zocken aufgibt, wenn man nicht mehr ansprechbar ist, sobald man unruhig wird, wenn man mal länger nicht an die Konsole darf, wenn man aggressiv wird, wenn man längere Zeit nicht spielt. Also es gibt quasi so einen Kriterienkatalog, so wie bei jeder Sucht. Und auch ich musste mir den aber erst anlesen, jetzt in Vorbereitung auf diese Sendung. Da habe ich mich schon gefragt, warum, wenn das wirklich so ein großes Problem ist. Und ich habe jetzt keinen Grund gefunden, warum ich da diesen Studien und den Zahlen nicht glauben sollte. Das kam alles aus wissenschaftlichen Quellen, ohne irgendwelche Förderungen von Videospielgegnern oder der Videospielindustrie. Da habe ich jetzt nichts finden können. Dann müsste man doch eigentlich da viel mehr drüber reden. Und das wundert mich so ein bisschen, dass das auch gar nicht im Zuge dieser ganzen E-Sport-Debatte kommt. Also man hat immer mal wieder rund um die großen Major-Turniere gibt es Artikel, auch in den in Anführungszeichen Mainstream-Medien, die einem nochmal verdeutlichen, was da gerade passiert. Also die im Grunde – ich verkürze es jetzt mal – der älteren Welt erzählt, was die jüngere Welt eigentlich gerade so macht. Ja, ich glaube, das ist das Problem. Also ich komme ja aus der jüngeren Generation. Ich bin jetzt 22 und ich muss meinen Eltern immer noch regelmäßig erklären, was da los ist. Und meiner Verwandtschaft und auch teilweise noch meinen Freunden. Ja und du verdienst ja Geld damit. Ja, richtig. Und die das zum Großteil jetzt auch mitbekommen, dass es das Ganze gibt. Und ich glaube, man kann erst wirklich differenzierter über das Thema sprechen, wenn das überhaupt erstmal als Thema akzeptiert wird. Weil mein Job, ehrlich gesagt die ersten Jahre, als Profi-Spieler, da war ich auf EA so ein bisschen Botschafter, immer nur war, den Leuten zu erklären, jetzt mal ein bisschen überspitzt gesagt, dass Gaming eine coole Sache ist und man sich dann nicht in der dunklen Ecke im Keller versteckt, sondern dass man sich damit ruhig trauen kann, auch selbstbewusst umzugehen, und so wie wir das jetzt hier machen, ganz normal drüber zu diskutieren, was daran gut ist und was daran schlecht ist, wie an allen anderen Sachen. Und ich glaube, diese Diskussion ist erst möglich, wenn erst einmal akzeptiert wird, dass das ein Thema ist. Und ich glaube, das machen die Medien gerade erstmal. Überhaupt das Thema so ein bisschen an, also die Anerkennung für das Thema zu gewinnen, weil das glaube ich gerade wichtig ist. Und dann kann man im nächsten Schritt, und ich denke, das wird jetzt kommen, auch gezielt einmal in die Materie eintauchen. Das hoffe ich zumindest. Ja, und dann stellt sich auch die Frage, wie sich das dann darstellen wird von Seiten der Veranstalter. Also wenn wir jetzt darüber sprechen, dass die DFL eine eigene Liga gegründet hat, dann wird das Thema ja auch da irgendwann mal auf die DFL zukommen. Was macht denn Konni die DFL da eigentlich?
Also die DFL, wie meinst du das jetzt, in Sachen Suchtprävention?
Nee, jetzt in Sachen, was es erstmal gibt im E-Sport-Bereich.
Ah, okay. Ja, also es ist keine eigene Liga, zumindest noch nicht. Die DFL hat einen Modus im Spiel FIFA 18 integriert. Das haben sie zusammen mit Electronic Arts gemacht, mit EA Sports. Und da gibt es also dann eine offizielle deutsche Meisterschaft, bei der wir jetzt am Wochenende eben bei dem Finale waren, Samstag und Sonntag. Malte war mit dabei als Analyst dann noch ein Kollege von Malte, der Benni. Wir haben dann zusammen kommentiert. Das lief, wie schon gesagt, auf Sport 1. Und das ist aber das Finale über zwei Tage. Davor gibt es eben verschiedene Möglichkeiten, sich dafür zu qualifizieren. Das Ganze geht los kurz nach Release von dem aktuellen FIFA Spiel mit Online-Qualifikationsturnieren. Das heißt, jeder, der das Spiel hat, kann einen Bundesligaverein picken, den er repräsentiert. Beispielsweise, keine Ahnung, der Klub geht ja nicht, weil es der zweite Liga noch. Nehmen wir Schalke 04, weil wir Tim mit dabei haben. Dann sage ich also, ich spiele in Königsblau. Und habe dann so ein Team, das genormt ist. Also alle Mannschaften sind dann genormt, alle Spieler sind gleich stark. 85, die Gesamtwertung. Und dann spielt man dort, muss eine bestimmte Anzahl an Spielen absolvieren. Und wenn man sich dort eben gut behauptet, kommt man eine Runde weiter und so weiter und so fort. Dazu gesellen sich dann auch Offline-Turniere, also Turniere, wo man hinfahren kann, um sich eben eine Teilnahme zu sichern bei dem großen Finale. Und das kommt dann eben alles zusammen. Und das geht dann über Monate hinweg. Erst die Online-Phase, dann verschiedene Offline-Turniere. Dann gibt es nochmal die Playoffs direkt bevor es zum Finale geht. Die haben in Düsseldorf stattgefunden. Und dort kristallisiert sich dann heraus, wer die besten 24 Spieler sind. Die sind gemixt eben aus verschiedenen Wildcard-Turnieren, aus Online-Qualifikanten und Offline-Qualifikanten. Und die treten dann an zwei Tagen an. Und am Ende gibt es dann eben eine Gruppenphase. Da sind es dann vier Gruppen gewesen auf den beiden Konsolen Xbox One und PlayStation 4. Und dann gibt es eine KO-Phase, wie man es halt kennt, aus einer normalen WM-EM. Und am Ende gibt es ein Finale. Und derjenige, der gewinnt, der bekommt dann eben die Trophäe. Das ist so eine kleine Meisterschale quasi und 25.000 Euro. Und ist offizieller deutscher Meister. Sozusagen lizenziert oder verifiziert durch die deutsche Fußballliga. Also schon ein sehr großer und wichtiger Titel. Ich würde fast behaupten, auch der größte national gesehen. Es gibt noch die ESL-Meisterschaft, die ausgewürfelt wird oder ausgespielt wird. Gewürfelt klingt wieder böse, ja ich weiß. Da ist jetzt auch ein Wochenende. Ich weiß noch nicht, wann dieses Tribünengespräch erscheint, aber jetzt am Wochenende am Samstag wird dann auch dort der Meister der Frühlings-Saison, der Spring-Season, bekannt gegeben. Das ist das, was die DFL macht, aber das ist erst einmal nur so der Modus. Sie machen ja auch dazu, überlegen sie sich immer, wie können wir denn noch mehr Bundesliga-Vereine dazu bewegen, sich vielleicht im E-Sport zu engagieren. Deswegen gibt es eben auch in diesem Jahr neu Wildcards für Vereine. Man hat sich also überlegt, welche Bundesliga-Vereine haben vielleicht Lust, mal E-Sports in irgendeiner Form auszuprobieren, ohne vielleicht gleich einen eigenen Spieler zu verpflichten und den unter Vertrag zu nehmen und den zu coachen und so weiter. Und da gab es halt auch eben das erste Mal die Möglichkeit. Ich glaube, Gladbach war mit dabei, die haben so ein Wildcard-Tournee veranstaltet. Da ist auch ein Spieler dann eben beim großen Finale mit dabei gewesen. Und ich glaube schon, dass die DFL – es ist nur eine Vermutung, kein Wissen – dass die schon bestrebt ist, da vielleicht irgendwann mal, wenn das hinhaut, eine Art Legensystem virtuell hinzubekommen. Aber das, denke ich, dauert noch ein bisschen, weil es ja auch einige Vereine gibt, die im Moment sehr vehement dagegen sind, sich dazu engagieren. Deswegen leider auch zwei große, zumindest ein großer, der BVB, ist da nicht so angetan.
Das Interessante ist, in Frankreich und den Niederlanden zum Beispiel sind die Vereine dazu verpflichtet, ein E-Sport-Team zu haben. Und wenn ich vorhin gesagt habe, fast alle Major League Soccer-Vereine, also der US-amerikanischen Fußballliga, haben einen Verein, dann ist es auch noch eine Frage der Zeit bis die letzten beiden. Die haben nur noch jetzt keinen gefunden. Da ging die Saison jetzt gerade los. Da ist es quasi auch in einer Kooperation mit dem Spielehersteller fix geworden, dass jeder Verein ein E-Sport-Team haben soll. Und der BVB, der hat dazu unter anderem das Zitat geliefert, auch wenn wir Hollywood-Filme und Bücher als Bereicherung empfinden, würde der BVB keine Schauspieler oder Autorengruppen als eigenes Team verpflichten. Auch wenn es sich als Lukratie für eine größere Zielgruppe erweisen würde. Es passt nicht zu uns als Fußballverein. Wir empfinden es für uns nicht als authentisch und echt. Andere Clubs werden dies naturgemäß anders bewerten. Welche anderen Clubsthemen könnten damit gemeint sein?
Alle anderen? Ich glaube, jetzt haben 16 von 18 Vereinen an dieser virtuellen Bundesliga auf irgendeine Art und Weise teilgenommen. Von daher sagt ja schon relativ viel aus. Und die Argumentation hier, lasse ich mal so stehen.
Ich glaube auch ehrlich gesagt, ja, das mag vielleicht auch so ein bisschen der Wahrheit entsprechen, das Zitat gerade. Aber ich glaube, das hat auch noch andere Ebenen. Und zwar, ich glaube, das ist immer noch der Fall. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Aber der BVB hat eine Clubpartnerschaft mit Konami, dem Spielehersteller von Pro-Volution-Zocker. Da haben wir das Spiel nochmal. Und alle großen E-Sports-Wettbewerbe im virtuellen Fußball finden aber in FIFA statt. Weil eben über die DFL und über die FIFA dort die Lizenzen offiziell vergeben sind. Und das ist eben sehr nah an der Fußball-Lizenzlogik auch angelehnt. Und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt, dass das auch noch ein großer Faktor ist, warum sich der BVB eben jetzt zum Beispiel auch bei der virtuellen Bundesliga, bei dieser Club Wildcats noch nicht integriert hat, weil sie eben da mit Konami noch eine Kooperation am Laufen haben. Ja, sehr guter und ich glaube richtiger Punkt. Aber jetzt stelle ich mir die Frage, Malte, ist das denn spannend, so eine virtuelle Bundesliga? Denn das, finde ich, ist der große Unterschied zwischen der Fußballsimulation FIFA und anderen großen E-Sport-Spielen, wie eben, wir haben sie alle schon genannt, Dota 2, League of Legends, Counter-Strike GO und so weiter und so fort. Nämlich bei FIFA sehe ich einfach nur ein Fußballspiel und das geht genauso manchmal eins zu null aus mit dem Tor in der ersten Minute wie in echtes Fußballspiel auch. Und so wie ich dem echten Sportfußball da Probleme attestiere mit Blick auf die Zukunft, auf kürzere Aufmerksamkeit spannen und so weiter und so fort, so sehe ich das im E-Sport-Bereich aus. Wenn ich mir – ich als Laie, also ein paar der Spiele kannte ich, aber zum Beispiel der ganze Dota-League of Legends-Bereich, das ist nicht meins. Habe ich nie gespielt, das heißt da stehe ich erstmal davor, wie es achala wenn es blitzt, hat man bei uns im Franken immer gesagt, also wie das Eichhörnchen wenn es blitzt. Verstehe ich erstmal gar nichts. Aber es packt mich, weil da passiert wahnsinnig viel. Ich verstehe noch nicht alles, aber es ist komprimiert auf einen kurzen Zeitraum. Am plakativsten ist es noch bei Counter-Strike, da sind die Spiele wenige Minuten lang, also die einzelnen Spiele und es ist immer was los. Aber bei FIFA hat man das doch nicht. Ja, also ich hatte das ja eingangs schon so ein bisschen auch gesagt, dass ich das selber auch durchaus kritisch sehe. Also es hat einerseits auch Vorzüge, dass FIFA eben so einfach zu verstehen ist, weil der Fußball einfach zu verstehen ist. Und es hat auch Vorzüge, dass Fußball der beliebteste Sport ist und entsprechend auch das Interesse am Spielen sehr groß. Und man kann einfach niedrigschwelliger sich mal kurz in die Konsole setzen und eine Runde zocken, als jedes Mal, da braucht man irgendwie gleich ein paar Leute auf den Fußballplatz zu gehen. Deshalb wirklich fast alle Fußballer und Fußballerinnen auch FIFA spielen. Also das ist wichtig, um einfach mal zu zeigen, wie relevant das Spiel als solches ist, also wie oft es auch in Deutschland zum Beispiel jedes Jahr verkauft wird. Die Community ist sehr groß. Auf der anderen Seite ist das Problem aber, dass diese große Community irgendwie, wie du es gerade schon gesagt hast, auch bespaßt werden möchte. Und da gibt es eben schon ein Überangebot am Fußball, meiner Meinung nach. Also es ist halt echt krass. Man kann jeden Tag Fußballspiele gucken, Fußballtalks sich anhören. Es gibt Fußballpodcasts, die dauern Stunden. Es ist unklar. Ja, auch das.
Furchtbar so was, furchtbar.
Ganz schlimm. Und dann sollen sich die Leute auch noch virtuell den Fußball angucken. Und da sind wir eben gefragt als Berichterstatter über das Thema, wie man da Anreize schaffen kann. Und ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt. Ich denke, der eine Vorteil ist, dass FIFA kürzer ist. Also ein Spiel geht meistens zweimal sechs Minuten. Mit Taktik-Einstellungen und so weiter sind es dann 15 bis 20 Minuten pro Spielrunde. Das ist recht kurzweilig. Du hast die Aufmerksamkeit sparen angesprochen. Also da sehe ich einen Vorteil. Das merken wir auch, dass die Leute sich das gerne mal reinziehen. Kann man dann ja auch auf YouTube nochmal kurz reinklicken oder so im Nachgang. Das ist schneller angeschaut als ein ganzes Fußballspiel. Und die andere Ebene – und da muss ich eben was tun – ist, dass FIFA Vorzüge hat, das Regelwerk des Fußballs zu innovieren. Also anders als der Fußball, wo das, glaube ich, schon eher noch was sehr verankertes, sehr Traditionelles ist. Da wird es, glaube ich, dauern, bis da mal Regeln verändert werden. FIFA könnt hier sozusagen Vorreiter sein, aus meiner Sicht, und einfach mal rum experimentieren. Und ich hatte gerade das Beispiel unseres Draft-Story-Cups genannt, wo wir eben die Spieler ihre Teams draften lassen haben, was mal eine ganz neue Komponente war. Und ich glaube, da muss man einfach kreativ bleiben. Und dann haben die Leute auch Lust, sich FIFA anzuschauen, obwohl es den Fußball gibt. Und dann ergänzen sich die beiden Themen auch ganz gut, weil die Spieler im Digitalen dann eben abgebildet werden. Also man spielt ja mit echten Fußballern. Und das ist auch für die Fußballer und für die Vereine sehr cool, dann da auch nochmal auf eine innovative Art und Weise abgebildet zu sein. Ja, aber andererseits spiele ich ja in der virtuellen Bundesliga mit den echten Fußballern. Aber die haben alle denselben Wert. Das heißt, ein Jerome Boateng unterscheidet sich von einem Mitchell Weisse nur durch die Körpergröße, das Aussehen und so weiter? Ja, das ist aber eine Besonderheit in der virtuellen Bundesliga. Grundsätzlich ist das in FIFA nicht so, sondern du hattest das bei League of Legends so benannt, wie es bei FIFA tatsächlich der Fall ist. Lionel Messi ist da eben schnell, ist flink, ist hohe Abschlussstark und hat genau die Attribute und Eigenschaften, die er auch im echten Fußball hat. Also das ist schon sehr nah an dem echten Fußball orientiert. Die virtuelle Bundesliga hat das nur eingeführt, ganz kurz, um die verschiedenen Vereine eben ungefähr gleich stark sein zu lassen. Und das ist genau mein Punkt, auf den ich hinaus wollte. Denn das Problem der DFL dürfte ja sein, wenn es dieses Regularium nicht gibt, ja dann spielen die Leute logischerweise nur mit Lionel Messi, Christiano Ronaldo und so weiter. Ja, aber auch da – ich denke mal, Konni hat das vorhin auch nicht gesagt, weil das hätte sich gleich noch komplizierter angehört – beim Finalturnier gab es nochmal einen ganz anderen Modus. Und ich glaube auch, da hat die DFL und auch EA Sports als Spielehersteller ein bisschen gelernt, dass dieser 85er Modus ehrlich gesagt ziemlich langweilig ist. Es hat auch noch ein paar andere Gründe, aber das wird jetzt sehr tief in die Materie gehen. Aber allein schon, dass alle Spieler gleich stark sind. Das hat ja irgendwie gar keine Anreize mehr. Es wurde dann jetzt beim großen Finalevent der Modus Ultimate Team gespielt. Und das ist in FIFA der beliebteste Spielmodus. Da kann man sich aus allen Fußballvereinen, aus allen Fußballspielern seine Lieblingsspieler zusammenbauen zu einem Team. Man muss dann so ein bisschen aufpassen, dass die die sogenannte Chemie haben, also dass die irgendwie in einer Art und Weise miteinander harmonieren. Aber wenn sie zum Beispiel in der gleichen Liga spielen, dann harmonieren sie per se immer schon. Und in der virtuellen Bundesliga war es jetzt so, dass man pro Fußballverein drei Spieler auswählen durfte. Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dass ich das sehr cool finde, aus der Berichterstatter-Sicht, weil das eben sehr wild war. Da haben dann drei Bayern-Spieler in dem FIFA-Spiel, also man wählt dann entsprechend seine Elf-Spieler plus die Ersatzbank. Da haben drei Bayern-Spieler mit drei Schalke-Spielern und drei Dortmund-Spielern gespielt. Und so hat man da sehr kreative Teams gesehen. Meine Frage an dich nur, Tim, wäre mal, wie ihr das eigentlich seht, dass auf einmal die Markenidentität da auch so ein ganz bisschen angekratzt wird, indem nämlich auf einmal doch ein Schalker mit einem Dortmunder spielt?
Wenn ich tatsächlich jetzt hier sagen würde, nein, das muss dann aber alles total Schalke-Brand sein, dann müsste ich viele Argumente von mir komplett widerlegen. Wir müssen uns einfach den Gegebenheiten hier anpassen und schauen, dass es auch attraktiv für den Zuschauer, für den Spieler usw. ist. Und so funktioniert es im FIFA-Bereich am besten. Und ich glaube, deshalb ist es für uns auch relativ unproblematisch, weil es soll ja ein Spielerlebnis sein und soll auch ein Zuschauerlebnis sein. Und wir wollen doch nicht zwingend alles hier kopieren, was im Fußball Status quo ist. Und ich glaube, das ist völlig unproblematisch für uns gewesen. Eins muss ich dabei sagen, ich bin ganz froh, wenn unsere Jungs keine Dortmund-Spiele haben.
So etwas habe ich mir schon fast gedacht. Und ich muss fairerweise noch dazu sagen, in der virtuellen Bundesliga war die Auswahl des Kaders auf die Bundesligaspieler beschränkt. Aber bei internationalen Wettbewerben kann man wirklich aus dem Ganzen schöpfen. Und da spielen dann fast alle Profis wirklich nur mit den Topstars. Also da spielt dann im Schalke Dress Christiane Ronaldo oder auch Legenden, die man spielt.
Und das ist auch schön zu sehen. Also ein guter Bulli oder ein Ronaldo.
Also das dann ein Ronaldo spielen, das finde ich dann auch wieder schön. Also ich glaube, das wird sich einfach auch noch so ein bisschen eingrooven. Aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich glaube, hier wird wirklich auf vielen Ebenen angesetzt und überlegt, wie das Produkt attraktiv sein kann, wie das für einen Zuschauer kurzweilig und spaßig sein kann. Und ich glaube, da kann der Fußball tatsächlich noch was lernen.
Ich würde gerne noch eine Sache ergänzend sagen, weil wir jetzt eben FIFA Ultimate Team angesprochen haben, der Modus, wo man eben alles zusammenholen kann. Das klingt jetzt bei Malte so, als könnte jeder sozusagen jederzeit alle Spiele auswählen. Das ist halt die Komponente, die es dann auch nochmal anspruchsvoll macht, denn diese Spiele kannst du natürlich nicht einfach frei zusammenstellen. Gut, die Pros schon, aber du als eigener Spieler musst dir diese Spielkarten – sind das ja eigentlich – erspielen oder erkaufen, je nachdem. Also es gibt halt diese Mannschaft wird zusammengestellt durch fiktive Karten, die du zusammenstellst und die musst du dir quasi erst erspielen oder erkaufen. Das macht es dann halt ein bisschen nochmal anspruchsvoller zuzugucken, weil der Zuschauer denkt sich, wer passt denn in mein Team vorne noch in der Sturmspitze ganz gut? Wie macht es denn der Spieler so und so? Welche Karten lege ich da nochmal drauf? Man kann nämlich diese Karten auch nochmal zu einem bestimmten Stürmertypus machen und so. Also es gibt schon noch Komponenten, fernab, alle haben 85, was wir eben hatten in den Online-Qualifikationsrunden und diesem FIFA-Ultimate-Team, das ist nochmal ein ganz ganz anderer Unterschied irgendwie so, auch, das haben wir auch gemerkt jetzt am Wochenende bei der Virtua in der Bundesliga, dass natürlich einige der Aufstellungen ähnlich sind, also ein Goretzka war immer mit dabei, jeder hatte Goretzka, ich kann mich an kein einziges Spiel erinnern, wo Goretzka gefehlt hätte, aber dann gibt es eben doch ein paar Variationen, wo man dann eben auch als Zuschauer lernen kann, der auch selber spielt, wer passt denn eventuell noch in mein Team rein und das macht den Modus dann eben, da sind wir bei dem Punkt EA, versucht da schon glaube ich noch ein bisschen eine Varianz zum Zum klassischen Fußballspiel eben über Foot zu bewirken. Wie kann ich denn mein Team zusammenstellen? Und das ist glaube ich auch aus Zuschauersperspektive, zumindest wenn man das Spiel selber spielt, auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Was bestimmt auch schon vielen Hörern und Hörern über den Weg gelaufen sein wird, bei ihren eigenen Lieblingsvereinen und vielleicht auch auf den Social-Media-Kanälen von anderen Vereinen, ist, dass alle Bundesliga-Vereine oder fast alle diesen Hype mit befeuern. Das heißt, man hat immer wieder Bilder, wo die echten Spieler ihre FIFA-Bewertung in die Kamera halten. Oder bei Instagram kann man sich nicht retten vor FIFA-Content. Und auch die Medienkonni machen da sehr, sehr aktiv mit. Also es ist unglaublich, welcher Hype um die neuen Werte, also wenn die Spieler ihre Updates erhalten und dann man eben gucken kann, wer ist in welchem Bereich besser oder schlechter geworden, da gibt es Klickstrecken auf Sportportalen. Es gibt eine eigene Kicker-E-Sport-Seite. Das ist unglaublich, welcher Hype um dieses Thema herum erzeugt wird. Und manchmal ist mir das aber persönlich, obwohl ich mich schon als noch dieser Gedankenwelt zugehörig bezeichnen würde, mir ist das manchmal zu viel. Jetzt brauchen wir jetzt auch Klickstrecken da. Also reicht es nicht, dass wir schon die Klickstrecken haben, das verdienen die Topstars im internationalen Fußball. Welche Rolle ist das?
Das sind die Spielerfrauen.
Oder so sexy sind unsere Handballsternchen.
Ich sage mal so, Klickstrecken an sich kann man generell hinterfragen. Das ist, glaube ich, kein Ding des E-Sports.
Ja, aber welche Rolle spielen da die Medien?
Denn letztlich setzen sie sich ja in eine – Also es bildet sich da eine Allianz zwischen einem Spielehersteller, der sehr gutes Geld damit verdient und sowohl Vereinen, die damit auch versuchen, Geld zu verdienen, und aber auch Medien, die ja auch berichten sollen. Und es ist nicht so, dass der E-Sport ein komplett unkritischer Bereich ist. Ich will ihn jetzt auch nicht schlimmer zeichnen als er ist, aber es gibt auch im E-Sport Betrug, es gab schon Dopingfälle, wir haben das ganze Thema der Spielsucht. Und in keinem anderen Bereich würde man das so akzeptieren, dass die Medien sich zum, ja, weiß nicht, fast so zum Steigbügel halten.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass die Berichterstattung zu positiv verläuft in Summe?
Ja, beziehungsweise stelle ich mir häufig die Frage. Sie berichten natürlich darüber, weil es eine Aufmerksamkeit hat, aber es gibt auch ganz viele Artikel, wo ich mir denke, okay, vielleicht war das jetzt auch nur ein Gefallen an den Spielehersteller EA, der ja auch Anzeigen schaltet in Medien oder vielleicht fließt da auch direkt manchmal Geld in Form von sogenannten Medienkooperationen.
Also das ist ja jetzt auch wiederum kein Thema, was der eSport exklusiv hat. Also so eine Nähe zu Herstellern, zu Werbetreibenden und so weiter, das gibt es ja auch schon in anderen Bereichen. Genauso machst du dich ja – jeder Bundesligaverein will natürlich auch Geld verdienen, wenn du also darüber berichtest und du weißt auch, wie es abläuft, wenn du mal ein Interview mit Thomas Müller bekommst, da wirst du in der Tendenz eher nicht so kritisch über den FC Bayern München berichten, weil dann war es dein letztes Interview mit Thomas Müller. Das ist – naja, ist so.
Warte mal, wenn ich Thomas Müller habe, der wird gegrillt von mir.
Ne, was ich damit sagen will, ist, es ist natürlich immer ein gewisses Fingerspitzengefühl gefragt und es gibt immer – du musst immer abwägen, was du machst, aber was bezahlte Kooperationen angeht, will ich mal hoffen, dass zumindest die Arbeitgeber, für die ich arbeite, in dem Fall Sport1 in Sachen E-Sports, dass sie das dann kennzeichnen würden. Ich stecke da natürlich nicht dahinter. Ich schreibe da jetzt nicht so viele Artikel. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es läuft.
Ja, ich habe dich an die Hand genommen und in ein vermintes Gebiet geführt.
Oh ja.
Ja, aber es gibt doch auch – ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt – Pressekodex oder sowas, also dass sich auch Verlage und Medienhäuser ganz sauber ihre Werte dort runterbrechen oder sagen, nach diesen Maßstäben arbeiten wir. Ich glaube, das Problem ist da auch ein bisschen größer. Das ist beim E-Sports auf vielen Ebenen immer wieder interessant zu sehen. Ich glaube, E-Sports ist einfach nur ein gutes Beispiel für die digitalen Entwicklungen. Und online Journalismus generell hat, glaube ich, diese Probleme, wenn man mal das Beispiel jetzt nimmt. Und E-Sports ist immer wieder nur ein Thema, was damit irgendwie im Einklang steht, weil E-Sports auch so etwas Neues ist. Und da können sich irgendwie alle ausprobieren. Und deswegen glaube ich irgendwie auch, dass es manchmal sogar ganz gut ist, wieder aus den alten Strukturen zu lernen. Ich möchte jetzt nicht bei Konni rumschleimen, aber ich habe zum Beispiel gemerkt, dass seine Art wie er FIFA-kommentiert sehr aus dem Fußball kommt und dass das dem FIFA-Kommentarber gut tut, weil wir manchmal vielleicht ein bisschen zu nördig da rangegangen sind, zu kleinteilig. Und genauso kann man auf ganz vielen anderen Ebenen auch, glaube ich, aus beiden Welten lernen. Und deswegen glaube ich auch in Bezug auf den Journalismus und die Berichterstattung, wird sich das jetzt auch alles weiterentwickeln und dann wird es irgendwann genauso den kritischen Kommentar geben, wie den Journalisten, der sich da irgendwo einschleimen möchte. Und jeder muss dann halt wissen, nach welchem Maßstäben und Werten er da agiert.
Ich meine, dass EA ein Stück weit eine Art Monopolstellung hat, weil wir tatsächlich ProEVO jetzt nicht zwingen, als ernst zu nehmende Konkurrenz, was zumindest die Reichweite und die Verkaufszeiten angeht, hinnehmen können. Natürlich haben die eine Art Monopolstellung. Aber was ist die Alternative dazu, nicht darüber zu berichten? Das kann es natürlich auch nicht sein, weil natürlich die Zielgruppe da ist. Die ist interessiert. Wir merken das bei FIFA. Malte hat die Klickzahlen vom Wochenende. Wir waren auf Platz 13 der YouTube Trends am Wochenende mit dem Finale. Dann also das On-Demand-Video, was danach automatisch generiert, da steht. Die Leute wollen natürlich auch das Zeug. Es ist eigentlich so, dass wir sagen, EA zahlt. Jetzt machen wir nochmal irgendwie eine Live-Reportage dazu.
Nein, absolut, also das wird man sicherlich auch an den Downloads dieser Folge merken, dass das Thema interessiert und auch eine große Öffentlichkeit hat. Ich frage mich nur, das ist jetzt allerdings auch spekulativ, deswegen können wir dann die Argumentation hier auch schließen, aber früher war es so, es war für EA Sports, den Hersteller, ganz, ganz wichtig, dass er die Lizenzen der Bundesliga-Spieler und der anderen Vereine hatte. Er hatte ganz großes Thema, hatte Pro Evolution Soccer, der einzige Rivale, nie und unter anderem deswegen, aber auch aus ein paar anderen Gründen, hat das nicht geschafft, sich zu etablieren und jetzt hat EA Sports ein Monopol. Und ich könnte mir aber eine Zukunft vorstellen, in fünf bis vielleicht zehn Jahren, wo der E-Sport-Bereich so wichtig geworden ist, auch für die Bundesliga-Vereine, die sich darin jetzt engagieren, dass sich dieses Verhältnis umdreht, dass es für die DFL ganz, ganz wichtig ist, dass ihre Spieler in EA Sports stattfinden und dass es nicht mehr so ist, dass EA Sports betteln muss und viele Millionen dafür zahlen muss, die Lizenzen zu bekommen. Das halte ich für ein denkbares Szenario. Ich glaube nicht, weil so sind die Lizenzen nicht aufgebaut. Also ich bin da jetzt auch kein absoluter Vollprofitin, würde ich da wahrscheinlich noch besser mit den Lizenzwelten auskennen. Aber so wie ich die DFL da kennengelernt habe, haben die einfach die Rechte an diesen ganzen Themen und wissen ganz genau um die Wertigkeit. Und am Ende machen die ein Bieterverfahren alle fünf bis zehn Jahre. Und wenn EA dann die Rechte nicht mehr kaufen möchte, obwohl das super wertvoll ist für die DFL da drin zu sein, gar keine Frage, lassen sie sich aber trotzdem dafür bezahlen. Das heißt, am Ende des Tages ist die Frage, wer die Rechte erhält. Und ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie man der DFL diese Rechte entziehen soll. Aber klar, das kann natürlich sein, dass die Vereine irgendwann auch besser verstehen, dass auch diese ganze digitale Ebene irgendwie eine eigene Welt ist und sich da neue Lizenz- und Rechtelogiken ergeben. Das kann natürlich passieren. Ja, vielleicht bin ich auch einfach ein bisschen zu kritisch gegenüber allem, was ein Monopol ist. Aber wie gesagt, wir bewegen uns jetzt hier ein bisschen im Becken. Ich wollte gerade sagen, also ich finde den Punkt da gut. Ich glaube nur, dann müsste man wirklich, kann man philosophisch sehr weit ausholen. Jaja, klar. Wie, also genau, wo Monopole okay sind und so weiter, kann man die Systemfragen ansetzen. Monopole sind nur im Fußballpodcast-Bereich okay. Das ist der einzige Bereich, wo ich das sehe. Und auch nur, wenn...
Da musst du noch dran arbeiten, oder?
Ja, ja, absolut, nee, es ist nicht mal Monopol. So groß möchte ich den Rasenfunk nicht machen. Aber wenn wir jetzt schon... Wir haben jetzt sehr viel über Schalke 04 gesprochen und jetzt auch über die DFL. Ich gebe die Frage erstmal an Konni und dann darf der Tim gerne noch auch noch reingrätschen, wenn er möchte. Was machen denn eigentlich andere Bundesliga-Vereine? Ich habe ja vorhin ganz, ganz viele aufgezählt.
Ja, in der Detailarbeit weiß ich es natürlich nicht, aber es gibt inzwischen schon eine große Anzahl an Vereinen, auch aus der zweiten Liga. Ich denke an den VfL Bochum. Ich denke aber auch an den 1. FC Nürnberg. Auch der Club hat ja zwei Spieler. Da ist schon Bewegung. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass wirklich in den letzten Monaten sich da sehr viel tut. Auch generell habe ich das Gefühl, dass EA eSports weiter fokussiert. Man sieht das anhand der neuen Formen der Weltmeisterschaft. Es gibt ja jetzt seit einiger Zeit diese Foot Champions Offline-Turniere, wofür man sich qualifizieren kann. Dann heißt die Weltmeisterschaft jetzt auch ein bisschen anders. Es gibt Global Series, Playoffs und so weiter. Da gibt es erst mal eine neue Struktur und auch bei den Bundesliga-Vereinen bei uns in der 1. und 2. Liga gibt es immer mehr, die sich da mit engagieren, Spieler verpflichten, unter Vertrag nehmen, teilweise auch Kooperationen. Der 1. FC Köln zum Beispiel hat ja mit SK Gaming kooperiert, einem traditionellen eSports-Team eigentlich. Er hat dann hier mit Mirza Jahic, der Vizemeister geworden ist am Wochenende bei der Virtuen Bundesliga, auch einen Spieler, der Köln repräsentiert. Also jeder Verein hat seine eigene Art und Weise mit umzugehen. Schalke, wie schon gesagt, haben wir bei Tim gehört. Die haben sogar nach Wuchs eine Art gecastet mit so einem Turnier. RB hat bei Schalke 04 den ehemaligen deutschen Meister abgeworben. Gian Jassala. Also da ist schon allein, dass es so einen Transfer gibt. Denn es war, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, auch der erste dieser Art in FIFA, in Deutschland zumindest. Da merkt man schon, welche Bedeutung das auch für die Bundesligisten bekommt.
Ja, kann ich im Prinzip alle so bestätigen. Ich glaube, das einzige Problem, was Fußballvereine oder überhaupt E-Sport-Organisationen mit FIFA haben, ist ganz grundsätzlich das Thema, dass FIFA extrem Einzelspieler basiert ist. Das bedeutet, dass sich sehr viel auch auf den einzelnen Spieler fokussiert und weniger um das Team, die Organisation um diesen Spieler herum. Das ist etwas, was Sportvereine so nicht gewohnt sind. Es gibt tatsächlich Gründe, warum die klassischen großen E-Sport-Organisationen bis vor kurzem im Prinzip alle keine FIFA-Abteilung integriert hatten, weil FIFA eher ein einzelner Spieler-basierter Sport ist. Das kommt ja auch aus dem klassischen Sport. Warum haben Tennis-Spieler traditionell keine Sportvereine, die sie vertreten? Weil es auch ein einzelner Spieler-basiertes Thema ist. Das ist so ein bisschen die Problematik im FIFA-Bereich für uns Vereine, dass das das ganze Arbeiten etwas erschwert und umgekehrt wieder, was uns das Arbeiten beispielsweise im League-of-Legend-Bereich leichter macht, weil es hier tatsächlich um das Team geht und weniger um den einzelnen Spieler, was ja so eine Vereinstruktur eher beinhaltet. Von daher müssen wir mal sehen, wohin der Weg hier geht. Leider Gottes arbeitet EA und die FIFA auch sehr autark von den Vereinen und dann eher mit den Spielern direkt, was uns auch nicht wirklich gefällt, weil es letztendlich Angestellte von uns sind. Aber das sind tatsächlich Detailthemen, die glaube ich zu weit reichen würden. Und so viel Zeit haben wir auch nicht mehr.
Übrigens, kleiner Fun-Fact. Der einzige Fußballverein, dessen E-Sport-Abteilung gemeinnützig ist, zumindest Stand 4. April 2018, ist natürlich Raberleipzig. Wie könnte es auch anders sein? Was mich aber zum letzten Thema führt, das ich gerne noch besprechen wollen würde, nämlich, das haben wir vorhin schon angesprochen, Tim, als wir über euer Engagement im E-Sport gesprochen haben. Da ging es viel darum, dass man als Marke wahrgenommen werden möchte, dass man in einem Bereich aktiv sein möchte, in dem sich Jugendliche aufhalten, in dem auch Geld verdient wird. Und das hast du ja auch beschrieben. Ihr wollt damit auch Geld verdienen. Stellt sich aber ja die Frage, wie eigentlich? Also sollen sich denn irgendwann mal die Leute von euch dann E-Sport Merchandise kaufen? Wird es über die Preisgelder laufen? Was sind denn eigentlich da die Monetarisierungsmöglichkeiten, die Schalke 04 anstrebt?
Also am Ende des Tages sind es im Prinzip alle Monetarisierungsmöglichkeiten, die der Fußballverein auch besitzt, außer – und das ist der große Unterschied – und so ist ja im Prinzip die Monetarisierung Fußball begonnen. Und das gibt es im E-Sport gar nicht vom ersten Tag an. Quasi das Thema Ticketing, eigene Veranstaltungen. Das haben wir nicht, dass wir irgendwie über Zuschauereinnahmen, bzw. Ticketeinnahmen Geld verdienen und dann auch über Catering und so weiter und so weiter. So ist ja im Prinzip der professionelle Fußball entstanden damals, dass Leute dann auf einmal Geld bezahlt haben, um den Leuten zuzuschauen. Das haben wir bei uns nicht. Alles andere. Wir haben eine super spannende Zielgruppe, was wiederum für ganz viele Unternehmen interessant ist. Wir haben eine extrem emotionale Marke. Also das Thema Sponsoring ist extrem wichtig. Digitale Monetarisierung, sei es über Plattformen wie YouTube, sei es über Plattformen wie Twitch. Großes Thema bei uns. Preisgelder aktuell zumindest noch nicht wirklich relevant. Merchandise, du sagt es kommt irgendwann, besteht ja schon. Also wir verkaufen ja unser E-Sport-Trikot bereits. Wir verkaufen unseren E-Sport-Hoodie bereits. Alles natürlich.
Also läuft das? Läuft das? Also ich habe auch Rasenfunk-Merchandise, aber es waren ja 20 Shirts.
Also wir sind noch weit, weit, weit entfernt davon, den Merchandise-Volumen unserer Fußball-Abteilung konkurrieren zu können. Aber wir verkaufen eine relevante Anzahl an Trikots. Und ich glaube, hier ist ja eher die Vision und die Möglichkeit der Trigger, anstatt wir haben jetzt hier ein Produkt, das so fort funktioniert und millionenfach verkauft wird. Ich glaube, wir müssen uns hier auch unsere Wahrnehmung und unsere Marke auch erst mal erarbeiten. Aber wir schauen einfach mal rüber nach Amerika, Cloud9 oder TSM. Für die Zuschauer, die es wahrscheinlich nicht wissen, das sind so die größten E-Sport-Organisationen weltweit. Die haben siebenstellige Merchandise-Umsätze. Damit kann man ja relativ einfach sehen, wohin das führen kann. Aber vielleicht um die Frage zu vereinfachen. Grundsätzlich ist das Finanzierungsmodell exakt das gleiche wie im Fußballabzüglichen Stadion.
Wenn ich mal kurz nachfragen darf, ist das eigentlich euer Ziel, dass irgendwann – so läuft das ja auch in der Bundesliga – bei euch im Stadion was los ist? Das könnte ja im E-Sport auch nicht unmöglich sein. Aber aktuell ist es eben so, dass Veranstalter wie die ESL, also Turtle Entertainment, so etwas übernehmen. Findest du die Aufgabenverteilung richtig oder würdest du sagen, es ist ein Ziel, dass ihr auch irgendwann mal Leute in euer Stadion holt?
Also es ist relativ komplex, weil ein Event zu veranstalten benötigt ja im E-Sport dann auch extrem viel technisches Know-how, Equipment und so weiter und so weiter. Wir sind in dem Bereich absolut keine Experten. Wir sind Experten auf dem Gebiet, Sportveranstaltungen zu organisieren. Manchmal auch Events im Bereich Musik und so weiter. Ein E-Sport-Event auf die Beine zu stellen – ich meine, Malte, du weißt es sehr, sehr gut – ist schon sehr komplex. Wir hoffen und wir gehen auch davon aus, dass wir bei uns im Stadion irgendwann auch E-Sports-Evente haben werden. Ob es dann tatsächlich eigene Spiele sind, also dass wir irgendwie sagen, wir tragen unser Meisterschaftsspiel in League of Legends auf oder in welchem Spiel auch immer, ist denkbar. Ist aber noch nicht in naher Zukunft tatsächlich unmöglich. Man muss ja auch dabei noch sagen, E-Sport-Events füllen Stadien, füllen Arenen, aber da reden wir immer noch von 12.000, 15.000 Leuten und unsere Felchens Arena umfasst 62.000 Leute. Das ist nochmal eine andere Dimension und eine andere Hausnummer, das Stadion zu füllen. Ich glaube, wenn wir mal einen Zuschlag für die League of Legends Weltmeisterschaft bekommen würden oder für einen Major in CSGO, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass sehr, sehr, sehr viele Zuschauer ins Stadion strömen. Aktuell, dass eins unserer Teams oder eins unserer Spieler ein Stadion füllt, so vermessen sind wir nicht, das zu glauben.
Und wie ist denn die Reaktion der Zuschauer auf das Engagement vom Bundesliga-Verein wie jetzt eben euch? Das muss man sich ja vorstellen, es gab ja schon vorher andere Teams. Es war ja nicht so, dass das mit Einstieg von anderen Sportvereinen in den E-Sport-Bereich gegründet wurde. Und da gibt es auch quasi den FC Bayern München des E-Sports und da gibt es schon quasi auch schon das Schalke 04 des E-Sports. Und dann kommt eben Schalke 04 und das sehr, sehr internationale Publikum des E-Sports denkt sich, bitte wer?
Also zum Glück sind wir als Fußballverein so bekannt, dass viele nicht bitte wer gesagt haben, sondern aha Schalke. Aber ja, in China und in den USA gab es natürlich auch Leute, die gesagt haben, bitte wer. Grundsätzlich, ich glaube Konni, du verfolgst die Community auch immer sehr, sehr stark, kann man sagen, dass es eher eine Begeisterung gab, dass jetzt auch große traditionelle Sportvereine sich diesem Thema widmen und damit ja auch dem Thema eine Anerkennung bieten und auch eine neue Berichterstattung darüber. Als dass es die Reaktion gab, oh nein, jetzt nehmen die uns den E-Sport weg, wie er mal war. Ich glaube, das ist so das Community-Feedback gewesen, zumindest aus meiner Wahrnehmung. Und die anderen Organisationen, ich glaube, da gab es auch so ein gemischtes Empfinden dabei. Also natürlich Fußballvereine, Sportvereine haben einen finanziellen Background, der gefährlich werden kann, also Konkurrenz stellen wir mit Sicherheit da. Umgekehrt bringen wir aber auch sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit in den Markt, was diesen Organisationen dann auch wieder extrem hilft. Also es ist da auch so eine Mischung aus beidem gewesen.
Also ich denke auch, dass es sich ganz gut gegenseitig befruchtet. Und ich kann eigentlich die Eindrücke von Tim auch nur so wiedergeben. Also ich hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass die Leute sich denken, oh Gott, was wollen jetzt denn die klassischen Vereine bei uns mit E-Sports? Haut bloß alle ab. Nee, ganz im Gegenteil. Also es wurde relativ positiv aufgefasst. Sieht man eigentlich auch ganz gut immer an den Social-Zahlen, also wie da reagiert wurde. Und doch, das war eher positiv, ja.
Gibt ja auch die Kooperationen. Also jetzt SK Gaming mit dem 1. FC Köln zum Beispiel, ein Traditions-Gaming-Team, ein Traditions-Husball-Verein, und man tauscht da wieder Expertise aus. Ich frage mich eher, wie das so in fünf bis zehn Jahren aussieht. Aber am Ende des Tages wird vielleicht einfach so das, was es an großen Teams gibt, nochmal ergänzt, um E-Sports-Teams, die es geschafft haben, mitzugehen. Es gibt jetzt ja auch E-Sports-Teams, die große Sponsoren reinholen oder auch Investoren, um da eben zu konkurrieren und wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben. Und ich glaube, das werden auch einige schaffen. Tim hat hier eben eine Marke wie Cloud9 oder ein Team wie Cloud9 angesprochen. Ich glaube, die werden sich einfach auch mit Schalke auf Augenhöhe begegnen können, auch noch in zehn Jahren. Ja, ich hatte da in der Vorbereitung häufiger den Vergleich – ihr müsst mir jetzt sagen, ob das schief ist – des Frauenfußballs, wo du eben auch etablierte Vereine hast, die auch eine Frauenfußballabteilung mit ihren Möglichkeiten in die Erste-Fußball-Bundesliga geführt haben, der FC Bayern, der VfL Wolfsburg und so weiter. Aber du hast eben auch noch Turbine-Potsdam, du hast noch FSC Frankfurt. Das heißt, Frauenfußball-Vereine, die da waren, bevor der professionelle Fußball, also der Männerfußball, das für sich entdeckt hat. Vielleicht könnte das eine Analogie sein. Außer ihr sagt mir, sie ist total schief. Okay, ihr seid auch einfach zu höflich. Das muss man an der Stelle sagen. Aber auf der anderen Seite stelle ich mir dann auch die Frage, wie verknüpft man denn dann eigentlich seine E-Sport-Abteilung mit dem eigentlich dahinterstehenden Verein? Also ich habe mir da Videos angeguckt, natürlich wie ihr das auf Schalke macht. Da kriegen dann die E-Sportler, die Gelsenkirchen zum Teil noch gar nicht aussprechen können, die kriegen dann eine Führung und ihnen wird erzählt, was für ein Verein dahinter steckt. Und das wird jetzt vermutlich jeder Verein machen. Also die Klubberer werden ihren E-Sportlern sagen, wir sind die, die immer gesagt wird, wir sind ein Depp, aber eigentlich sind wir ganz cool. Und der VfB Stuttgart macht das bei seinen anders. Aber so treten die ja in der Szene gar nicht auf. Gibt es da vielleicht auch noch so einfach zwei komplett verschiedene Welten, dass Leute mit einem Fußballhintergrund sich das Schalke 04 E-Sport Team angucken und sagen, ja klar, in der ersten Saison abgestiegen, das passt ja. Oder schon wieder nicht Meister geworden, das passt ja. Und die E-Sport Community, die vielleicht im Fußball nicht so tief drin ist, sich einfach nur denkt, okay, den Gamer, den kenne ich noch von daher, der ist total gut, wenn er – ja gut, da kenne ich mich jetzt leider nicht aus – mit der rechten Maustaste hier den Adler hüpfen lassen muss.
Also meiner Meinung nach ist es ganz klar, dass wir uns auch unsere eigene Identität im E-Sport erst mal erarbeiten müssen. Was wir, was du ja schon gerade gesagt hast, natürlich machen, ist es unseren E-Sportlern die Schalke Welt näher zu bringen. Und das bedeutet aber nicht, dass jetzt unsere E-Sportler auf einmal Fußballverrückt sind und unser Steigerlied rauf und runter singen können. Das können auch viele unserer Fußballer nicht. Viele unserer Fußballer sind auch nicht, nur weil sie dann nach Schalke wechseln auf einmal Gelsenkirchener durch und durch. Das ist ja auch naiv zu glauben. Aber es gibt hier Identitäten und Werte des Vereins, die wollen wir unseren Spielern vermitteln. Und das geht aber auch nicht von jetzt auf gleich. Und das geht auch nicht, wir laden die einmal nach Schalke ein, lassen die in ein Spiel gucken und die haben es verinnerlicht. Ich glaube, das entwickelt sich dann, umso länger ein Spieler bei uns in der Organisation ist, umso mehr weiß er Schalke zu lieben und zu schätzen und auch unsere Werte zu verstehen. Aber das ist, glaube ich, in allen Bereichen, im klassischen Sport, im E-Sport, in was auch immer ist es gleich. Man kann ja nicht erwarten, verpflichtet jemanden, der hat direkt das Schalke-Virus gepackt. So funktioniert die Welt ja nicht. Und ich glaube, wir tun auch sehr gut daran, tatsächlich hier eine sehr eigene Art der Kommunikation aufrechtzuerhalten, wenn die Zielgruppe, die hier E-Sport lebt und liebt, ist anders als der Fußballfan oftmals. Und so müssen wir mit ihm ja da und auch reden, kommunizieren und wie es so schön immer heißt, im digitalen Engagement betreiben.
Damit wäre auch hier mal ein Bingozettel jetzt dann voll der Anglizismen, die in dieser Folge verwendet wurden. Dann würde ich euch alle drei gerne nochmal abschließend zu einer Zukunftsvision oder um eine Zukunftsvision bitten. Vielleicht fangen wir mal bei Konni an. 2025, Deutschland. Was wird am Wochenende mehr geguckt? E-Sport-Veranstaltungen oder die Fußball-Bundesliga?
Die Fußball-Bundesliga.
Warum?
Also ich glaube, ich habe ja auch schon einige Prognosen gehört und das ist ja immer so ein bisschen, man kann ja damit richtig liegen oder falsch. Aber ich glaube, dass der Fußball in seiner klassischen Form in Deutschland und in der Kultur so derbe verankert ist, dass FIFA oder was auch immer bis dahin für ein Fußballspiel sich durchsetzen wird, es sehr schwer haben werden, dem Fußball den Titel strittig zu machen. Aber ich glaube, bis dahin wird auf jeden Fall die Reichweite und auch die Zuschauerschaft deutlich nach oben gehen, aber immer noch weit weg vom klassischen Fußball, denke ich.
Malte, wie denkst du über die Zukunft 2025? Welchen Rang wird eSport haben? Also ich muss dazu nochmal sagen, dass ich finde, dass man eSports auch ein bisschen zerteilen muss. Also jedes Spiel ist ein Sport an sich. Und ich finde, dass für einen Fußball jetzt ein bisschen hart mit allen Sportarten auf einmal konkurrieren zu müssen, aber das kriegt der Fußball, denke ich, schon hin. Also ich würde sagen, 2025 immer noch Fußball so die wichtigste Sportart, aber ich glaube, eSports in der Gänze, also alle Spiele zusammengerechnet, werden da schon nahe rankommen und dann Nummer zwei dann sein.
Also ich hatte auch die Frage so verstanden, wie FIFA im Vergleich zur Bundesliga abschneidet. Wenn wir natürlich eSport komplett nehmen, Ich meinte eSport komplett, ja. Okay, dann würde ich, was FIFA und Bundesliga angeht, bleibe ich bei meiner Meinung. Ansonsten ist das sehr schwer abzuschätzen. Wir bekommen es immer wieder mit, dass teilweise eSportstitel, die etabliert waren, dann wieder nicht mehr so den Stellenwert genießen, neue Spiele dazukommen, eben Fortnite oder sowas. Das ist unfassbar schwer. Aber wir sehen es ja jetzt schon bei Einschaltquoten im Vergleich zu klassischen Sportwettbewerben. Die sind ja jetzt schon teilweise höher als die NBA-Finals zum Beispiel. Deswegen würde ich da zumindest sagen, mindestens auf Augenhöhe, wenn nicht sogar der eSport ein bisschen weiter vorne ist. Und Malte hat eine Sache wichtig angeschnitten, ich weiß, Tim muss gleich los. Nur ganz kurz, eSport ist sozusagen wirklich der Oberbegriff. Und diese ganzen Spiele sind die Sportarten. Ich glaube, das muss man auch immer wieder noch im Hinterkopf behalten.
So, und Tim, jetzt noch deine Prognose. Wo steht der eSport und wo steht dann Schalke 04? Sag jetzt bitte nicht an der Weltspitze.
Also tatsächlich sage ich auch, Fußball wird wahrscheinlich für immer Zuschauersport Nummer 1 in Deutschland bleiben. Ich gehe ein bisschen weiter als Malte und Konni hier und sage, dass es ein Computerspiel geben wird, also ein Titel, wie wir im Fachjargon sagen, dass es einen Titel geben wird, der die Nummer 2 in Deutschland sein wird. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es ein Computerspiel geben wird, das mehr geschaut wird als alle anderen Sportarten in Deutschland. Welchen weiß ich, kann ich jetzt nicht so genau sagen, aber da bin ich mir sehr sehr sicher. Und das sind meine Prognosen hier. Ich glaube allerdings, dass der Fußball immer das Kind des Deutschen bleiben wird. Und wo steht Schalke? Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass wir zu den etablierten Traditionsvereinen im E-Sport gehören werden. Das ist dann in 25 Jahren oder wann auch immer möglich zu sagen, wir haben Tradition.
Dann freuen wir uns schon alle auf die E-Sportler, die nach dem Sieg der Schalke wappen küssen und den großen Transfer, wo dann der E-Sportler sagt, ich habe schon früher in Schalke E-Sport, Bett, Wäsche geschlafen. Das werden herrliche Zeiten. Ich danke euch allen zuvorderst Tim Reichert, Chief Gaming Officer des FC Schalke 04, bei Twitter, Tim Reichert14, Tim, vielen Dank für deine Zeit. Und außerdem danke an Malte Hedderich, selbst FIFA-Spieler, Experte der Tobias Escher des E-Sports im FIFA-Bereich. Er würde das selber so nicht zugeben, aber so ist es einfach. Ed Malte Hedderich auf Twitter und Teil vom Beepard Gaming, den kann man beiden sehr gerne folgen. Malte, vielen Dank, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Das freut mich. Und Spaß gemacht hat es auch, Konni Winkler zuzuhören. Ed Konni auf Twitter, es lohnt sich sehr, ihm dort zu folgen, denn da bekommt man einen perfekten Mix aus Fußball-Content und E-Sport-Content. Ich möchte Konni sehr, sehr empfehlen an alle meine Hörerinnen und Hörer. Lieben Dank dir, Konni, dass du mit dabei warst.
Danke dir und schön, dass es mal geklappt hat.
Ja, das finde ich auch. Und auch danke an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die Interesse an dieser Folge hatte. Das war Tribünengespräch Nr. 17. Hört euch auch die anderen 16 an. Da geht es dann ein bisschen um härtere Fußball-Themen in diesem Sinne. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, wie häufig der E-Sport hier noch stattfinden wird im Rasenfunk. Meine Prognose? Gar nicht so selten. Da werden wir uns alle dran gewöhnen. Und bis dahin weiß ich dann vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen mehr. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke fürs Zuhören, macht's gut, bis bald, ciao!
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.